what do you do when the sun turns wrong
when light which once represented life
joy and warmth becomes a symbol of death
and destruction do you hide inside
shutter the windows keep out the light
by any means necessary do you Retreat
underground where the sun's Rays cannot
penetrate burrowing into the dark and
the cold do you simply give yourself to
it accepting that there is no escaping
something so vast so far-reaching as
sunlight itself and allow yourself to be
lost in the end of all things we've
covered this possibility before SCP 001
when day breaks or STD loocks proposal
it's difficult to know what any given
person might do in such harrowing
circumstances after all we have always
learned to love the light and fear the
darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that
Paradigm shifted the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death the
source of all life on Earth of all
warmth transforming in an instant from
the Sun as we know it to a Napoleon
class SCP that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always
feared the light something that
prioritizes Solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when Daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one scp096
scp096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
Solitude would be in much Danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to Slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and pting that might
sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of Flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him him as they never looked at his face
all he did was stay in his room and
never go outside the outside frightened
him terribly though he was not concerned
with the deadly sunlight or the
possibility of it melting him as it had
so many others he was much more afraid
that someone some unlikely Survivor
clinging to their original life might
look at him that they might see his face
that was simply too distressing to risk
he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows
one day though we couldn't say how many
days after the end of things it had been
he was weeping alone in his former cell
the days blurred together spent the same
way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had had
any food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
was coming down the hall as much as it
could be called a hall anymore she was
coming towards his room to disrupt his
miserable peace he heard her steps cross
the threshold of his room and her voice
broke into a terrified scream no doubt
at the unexpected sight of a pale naked
creature weeping in the corner of what
she expected to be an empty room
startled by the first loud sound he'd
heard in a long time in a world that had
mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized Screams had faded
into the soft slap of Flesh and slime on
the ground he turned around he shouldn't
ordinarily he wouldn't but he couldn't
stop himself there he saw a woman wide
eyes filled with tears face stre with
dirt a small child next to her holding
her hand and clinging to her leg just as
he saw the woman she saw him she saw his
face anger boiled over inside of him and
he let out a scream wild Primal and
filled with inhuman rage she could not
be looking at him seeing his face he
couldn't let her the woman ran with the
child in toe panicked by the wild Roar
and the sight of him standing upright
before her the anger faded as she left
his sight making her way down the hall
into the stairs but then he remembered
she had seen his face he could not let
her leave it was time to do something he
never thought he'd have to do again hunt
his heightened senses picked up the
sound of muffled footsteps coming up
through the floor below him she was
downstairs just beneath the floor where
he was standing his instincts kicked in
and his body moved almost of its own
accord he lifted his long long arms
above his head and drove his hands down
into the floor it was weakened by by the
ravages of the elements and time and
crumbled under his unnatural strength he
dug his claws into the plaster tearing
it apart and cracking it into pieces he
pushed his claws in deeper and deeper
until he could feel them breaking
through the other side he pulled the
floor apart until the hole was wide
enough to fit through then dropped down
to the room below he spotted the woman's
back fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a Mad Dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
Terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no Escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she had crossed
from the Shadows into the harsh light of
the Sun the woman's eyes widened in Grim
understanding of her fate he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious Rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the Sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening Splash her eyes were
next popping out of their sockets and
hanging loose and Limp on her cheeks and
dangling from siney strands she tried in
vain to stuff them back into place but
they squished in her hands like overripe
fruit she attempted to run into the
comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous Flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
Agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all sobbing and roaring in
frustration she was gone and he would
never get the satisfaction of ending her
The Infernal son had stolen her from him
now she was nothing but a wet Shadow
like the rest of the humans had become
long ago he heard the sound of a soft
SOB behind him a tiny human voice he
turned looking for the source there was
the little girl he had almost forgotten
about her she was calling out for her
mother and crying and she was looking
right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake take him but
instead there was nothing why wasn't he
angry she was looking at his face so why
then he realized her eyes were on him
but she did not see him she was blind
she approached the creature her arms out
stretched following the sound of his
crying she touched his hand with her own
tiny fingers so small and fragile and
asked Mommy then he felt something he
had never felt before tenderness care a
desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm ever felt anything but sadness
anger or fear overcome with this
softness he wrapped his arms around the
child and hugged her close she hugged
him back tightly and the room went quiet
as they both stopped crying from that
day on they became a family of sorts
they lived together and he took care of
her she didn't know what he looked like
and had no no idea he might be something
to fear to her he was safety he was home
for the first time in his long awful
life he felt like a Human Instead of a
monster he would scavenge food for her
bring her fresh water lay down stolen
blankets and pillows so she would have a
soft place to rest he even found her a
ratty worn teddy bear amongst the rubble
and gave it to her as a gift she
clutched it to her chest and thanked him
and for once his tears were those of joy
in this cursed World they had found
something like happiness in one another
he knew he would protect her no matter
what then one day everything changed the
creature and the little girl were
playing in the abandoned sight making up
little games together when he took a
break to look out at the window and
monitor their surroundings outside the
evil Red Sun waited when he turned back
the little girl was gone one of the
shadowy creatures once human was
imitating his voice to lure her away he
could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased
after her the only thing he had ever
loved and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light she screamed as one
of her arms began to melt in the light
and he knew what he had to do he grabbed
her and pulled her back inside using his
body to Shield her from the horrible
Rays as he wept over her his tears
stopped her body from melting any
further but his body continued to fall
apart it was too late for him he ran as
far as he could once he transformed he
did not want to end up hurting the girl
he ran until his legs melted away and he
could not run anymore he had reached the
shoreline and stared out at the ocean
unable to move anymore he screamed a
final time in agony in heartbreak in
mourning for the happiness he had
finally found and now would lose but at
least he knew as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone that the girl
would be safe and then he was gone and
the world was quiet Jack was swimming
deep underwater wondering why he had
such a pounding headache when suddenly
he had a terrifying realization he had
no idea where he was or what he was
doing there was a nagging feeling that
he must have a specific reason to be
here you don't just end up deep in the
ocean with a diving suit on by chance
yet he had no idea what he was supposed
to be doing he wasn't sure he cared
either he was more worried about the
throbbing pain in his head and the
vision of two eyes staring at him out of
the dark that he couldn't get out of his
mind his heart began to race as he
wondered what to do and how to get help
he was in the middle of the ocean and
appeared to be all alone he couldn't see
anything in the Dark Water except for
this weird gray substance in front of
him maybe he was going to die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud about
how he was consumed by sickness and that
Darkness was all around him this is the
story of one of the most powerful and
dangerous anomalies yet discovered SCP
3000 before Jack's descent into despair
the SCP Foundation had mandated an
exploratory Expedition off the coast of
Bangladesh after receiving a few strange
reports from locals and fishermen the
foundation suspected an SCP was lurking
in the water and positioned a few
Personnel to investigate the crew
expected danger or maybe even death but
what they got instead was far stranger
and more ominous all of the men had been
verified to be in sound mental States
when the mission set out but a few of
them reported feeling strange and uneasy
as the submarine descended into the
ocean before long a veteran agent named
Dr Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and Jitter ing as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to Seda him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as SCP 3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with a head as big as a
town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blend blank look in his eyes as
if the light and life had left him and
he just began screaming no repeatedly
again and wouldn't respond to any
attempts to calm him down not that
anyone else was very capable of calming
him down at this point even the crew
members that had been holding up well
were starting to act strangely and
nobody could get the image of these
ominous eyes out of their heads then
things went from bad to worse Williams
began screaming and shouting madly as if
he was being tortured by an unseen Force
the men tried to restrain him but it was
no use he began smashing his head
against the submarine window until it
cracked putting the whole mission in
everyone's life at risk he fell to the
ground injured chanting that there was
nothing whatever that meant it was an
emergency scenario they began applying
first aid to Williams as the submarine
ascended to the surface as quickly as
possible before the pressure of the
ocean caused the cracked window to
explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the the same thing on the
days that came afterward the image of
the eel-like creatur's eyes seemed
burned in their minds permanently it
would haunt their waking hours for the
rest of their lives and sleep was no
Escape either as they would appear in
both their dreams and nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about the
strange Beast already there were many
theories and question marks surrounding
SCP 3000 how big was it really was it
sentient what was the liquid for none of
the men who had been on the previous
Miss were willing to return to the
waters but a new group of Brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned the
hard way that bravery and foolishness
are often mistaken for the same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in dive suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail and to eliminate the chance of
one team member self- sabotaging the
submarine killing them all they were
transported to the location by boat and
the three men splashed into the ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well well in casee anything
went wrong the three of them were
tethered together for extra security but
the deeper into the ocean they swam and
the closer they got to SCP 3000's
location they got the stranger things
became just like on the last mission
first there were a few minor cases of
confusion one of the team Jack thought
it was his responsibility to lead the
navigation but another Roberto also
thought it was his job in fact
navigation was actually the job of a
third team member air but he seemed to
have forgotten everyone was getting
confused the team list listening in on
the conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away 2 years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that was holding them together all alone
Jack couldn't remember where he was or
why he was here he desperately looked
around to try and gauge his surroundings
but he could only see Darkness all he
could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of Despair
and anxiety and this weird gray fluid
that was now floating in front of him
the foundation listened as Jack started
reciting a creepy speech about being on
the edge of nothing inches from Oblivion
with a sickness in his mind and nothing
but a pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be SCP 3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going on then the gibberish started
again two of the men were screaming that
Jack had just been swallowed whole and
that they were being sucked in too why
couldn't they just swim away it was
chaos but then a few moments later
Roberto spoke into the radio saying he
was floating alone in the middle of the
ocean and had now moved away from the
eyes of SCP 3000 he finally seemed
capable of forming coherent thoughts and
speech after what had just happened
Roberto now had a theory he thought that
somehow it was impossible to think
straight around SCP 3000 when he'd been
close enough to see the eyes Roberto had
felt a throbbing pain in his brain and
been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of SCP 3000 now and
Roberto was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later he had acquired some very
important data but he seemed to have
lost all hope of preserving his life
Roberto started telling the team over
the radio that he was dying and that his
heart rate was too high but cautioned
that it would be too dangerous for
anyone to try and rescue him the
Personnel continued to try and
communicate with Roberto to figure out
what was going on but his words had
stopped making any sense until finally
he went quiet minutes turned into hours
hours into days and still there was no
sign of Roberto or the rest of the
divers after 3 days His Radio which had
only been sending a steady stream of
Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y99 a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia y 99 causes head pain
paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams and the diving Trio the
collection of Y 99 might have resulted
in two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by SCP 3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause un desirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain y 99 is somewhat
ethically questionable for most people
SCP 3000 produces y99 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated declass
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
human ity now the foundation protects
SCP 3000 as best as it can guard
something hundreds of kilometers long
the area is carefully patroled and
members of the public are not allowed to
enter the part of the bay where it
resides anybody who accidentally comes
into contact is contained eventually
another pair of foundation doctors went
down in a submarine to try and learn
more about SCP 3000 one became so
affected by y 99 that he began
hallucinating he started talking about
anant shesha the king of serpents in
Hinduism ananta is believed to be all
that will be left after the end of the
world because it exists throughout all
of time simultaneously the doctor said
he believed that this was in fact an
anesa that SCP 3000 simply shows us that
eventually everyone dies and Fades into
the darkness of Oblivion right before he
exited the submarine and swam right into
his mouth luckily for now SCP 3000 seems
to be in a sort of hibernation state it
rarely moves and it doesn't hunt
although it will eat when fed but no one
knows when or if it'll wake or what it's
capable of if it does will it destroy
the world or simply drive us all insane
many children across the
English-speaking World grew up hearing
Mother Goose nursery rhymes about mice
running up clocks old women living in
shoes and one unfortunate egg by the
name of Humpty Dumpty but have you ever
heard the rhyme about the Crooked Man
most of us who heard that particular
poem remember it like this there was a
crooked man and he walked a crooked mile
he found a crooked six pence against a
crooked style he bought a crooked cat
which caught a crooked Mouse and they
all live together in a little crooked
house a little bit odd but hey most
nursery rhymes are when have you ever
seen a little girl sitting on a tet
eating some Kurds in way what even is a
tough it honestly what are Kurds in way
let's just move on residents of the
Sleepy English Hamlet of TBI in
Oxfordshire hear a more menacing version
of the rhyme about the crooked man sung
as a song on playgrounds shared in hush
tones when the grown-ups aren't
listening it goes like this there lived
a crooked man who made a crooked deal he
kept a crooked cane and his catch in
crooked cre he stole a crooked child who
cried a crooked squeal and that crooked
little man was broken on the wheel it
sounds just as inscrutable as any other
nursery rhyme but there is a dark tone
to it that seems a bit out of place
especially when you compare it to the
other somewhat sheery version This
creepy alternative to the Crooked Man
nursery rhyme seems to only be found in
the town of TMI and unfortunately for
the residents of that town there is a
deadly truth behind its words many years
ago the SCP Foundation became aware of a
mysterious pattern in this unassuming
town every 12 years over a period of
roughly 70 days something horrible would
happen to Town's people who happen to be
alone and endure after dark when they
were discovered by a neighbor a family
member a friend or even the police they
would be unresponsive suffering from
full body paralysis or appearing to be
effectively brain dead this was not the
most unusual aspect of the phenomenon
though the victims were all grotesquely
transformed their long bones covered in
dozens of compound fractures combined
with excess cartilage and ous tissue
their limbs would become distended
stretched and deformed into long gnarled
appendages like the limbs of an ancient
tree one of the recovered victims had a
forearm measured at over 2.4 M long
another had to be placed in a specially
outfitted hospital bed as his spine and
legs had stretched to the point where he
was 12.5 M tall local police and doctors
alike were left scratching their heads
what had happened to these people
clearly something horrible had been done
to them but there was no actual evidence
of a crime no one had been murdered and
there was no evidence of forced entry at
any of the victim's homes there was
however one other piece to the Crooked
puzzle just before a victim was found
their place of residence would visibly
degrade and warp the structure itself
breaking in places until portions
collapsed in or became slanted roofs
would Tilt at an unsafe angle chimneys
would fold over and door frames would
twist until no ordinary person could
pass through them safely this happened
every 12 years for decades and none of
the people of TBI could do anything
about it in fact they rarely ever so
much as spoke of it terrified of
admitting the truth of their Town's
curse in so many words instead they
spoke about the phenomenon in inuendo
meaningful glances and pleas to keep
loved ones company at night and through
a simple children's rhyme one doctor
tasked with treating survivors of the
horror decided to do something as the
12-year Mark began to approach once more
he reached out to a research he had
known years ago a man who specialized in
The Unexplained things that modern
medicine had no answer for this man had
left medicine behind and was now working
for the SCP Foundation at the time of
contact there were approximately 6
months to go until the phenomenon would
begin to strike once more the foundation
needed to act quickly in order to
collect more information and hopefully
find a way to stop the terror of TBI
once and for all with about a month to
go until the danger would reappear a
member of d-class personnel referred to
as d209 was placed in a foundation owned
house in town audio and visual equipment
were installed throughout the house in
order to monitor it for any anomalous
activity and to make sure d209 remained
at his post for the first month of his
stay d209 did not experience anything
unusual he spent his time drinking tea
baking pies and catching up on his
reading he even thanked the foundation
for the unexpected station unfortunately
on his 43rd day in tmbi things changed
as d209 sat in bed reading a novel by
the Lamplight the camera feed in the
living room began to glitch a vertical
Distortion appeared with a jagged
pattern that began to make its way
across the room from the front door it
was as if something was coming inside
but the camera could not pick up its
image the Distortion continued through
the hallway until the camera placed
there cut out entirely d209 suddenly
closed his book as the sound of
scratching came from the floor below he
began to slowly climb out of bed
listening for further sounds as the
entity continued to make its way through
the house toward him movement was
apparent on the video feed but there was
too much interference for any image of
the creature to be made out d209 froze
in his tracks as he heard footsteps slow
and certain coming up the stairs toward
him he ran to the window attempting to
pry it open and make an escape but it
would not budge with increasing
desperation he grabbed grabbed his
bedside lamp and threw it at the window
attempting to shatter the glass the lamp
broke apart but the window remained
stubbornly intacted as he scrambled for
an Escape Route something knocked at his
bedroom door d209 called out toward the
door who is it who's there but there was
no response identify yourself still
whatever stood on the other side said
nothing holding the remains of the lamp
in one hand as a makeshift weapon d209
slowly reached for the doorknob and open
the door with a sudden pop every light
bulb in the vicinity burst including
Foundation provided flood lights
positioned outside of the house there
was the sound of snapping and then an
agonized Scream the camera adjusted to
the lack of light in the room allowing
for a clear image of
d209 he was wailing and holding his
right arm which appeared to be broken
just above the elbow the arm began to
stiffen and elongate indicating
impossibly fast bone growth screw this
you're not taking speaking me I'm
getting out of here alive he yelled
running down the hallway he collapsed as
another snapping sound echoed throughout
the hall my legs broken set out please
he called to someone anyone who might be
watching the feed slowly painfully he
pulled himself to his feet he lifted his
right arm to the camera showing that it
had been broken again below the elbow
pointing in the opposite direction of
the first break what are you doing help
me he screamed it it's doesn't even hurt
anymore that can't be right I I don't
know what's happening to me as he
continued to yell at the cameras he
limped towards the stairs attempting to
make his way down to the first floor he
missed a step lost his balance and fell
all the way down 12 loud snaps were
heard as he went when he landed on the
ground his bones were broken in several
other places only to be immediately set
where they had broken as he screamed he
dragged himself into the living room
battling against his own body which had
become something foreign to him his arms
were growing longer now around 2 m long
and his legs stretched out of the
camera's view presumably into the
hallway suddenly he stopped crawling his
eyes widening no no
no no he whimpered before suddenly being
dragged backwards out of the camera's
view due to the presence of the entity
interfering with the cameras all
visibility was lost at this point there
was how ever still a live audio feed the
microphones picked up an hour of
snapping and screaming until d209
eventually went quiet then all that
could be heard was a wet sucking sound
followed by a thumping meanwhile at the
hospital 27 other victims of the entity
were lying in hospital beds as d209 met
his unfortunate fate all of the
hospitalized victims began to experience
seizures at the same time and seized for
several minutes five patients were
killed and two researchers were injured
in the chaos after the incident at the
hospital reports of a seismic event at
the edge of town began to circulate
because there had been no actual
earthquake in the area the research team
realized that this disturbance had to be
somehow related to the phenomenon they
planned to investigate in order to learn
more about the entity behind it all
which they had now officially designated
s CP 783 the Crooked Man a team of
personnel were sent to investigate the
site of the mic event only to find a
group of TB towns folk clustered around
the area in a field at the south of town
the crowd refused to let the researchers
through and would not budge until one
researcher agent Collins pulled out her
firearm and fired a shot into the air
the sound frightened the crowd and they
realized this mysterious Foundation
really meant business where the crowd
had been agent Collins could see toes
unnaturally long crooked toes poking up
out of the ground they were going to
need some help and a lot more shovels to
uncover this Mystery by the next day a
dig Team had uncovered a mass grave
filled with victims of SCP 783 there
were dozens of elongated bodies spread
throughout the 5 m wide hole stacked on
top of each other with their heads
facing down and their arms outstretched
towards the bottom of the pit their
limbs had grown around each other
twisting together to the point where
they could not be removed one at a time
while trying to collect a tissue sample
from one of the bodies researcher singer
lost his balance as the ground beneath
him gave way and he fell he attempted to
find a foothold and climb back up but
fell through the gnarled arms and down
into the pit thinking quickly agent
Collins grabbed a rope and tied it
around her waist she would lower herself
down into the grave and would signal
when she was ready for them to pull her
out agent Collins descended into the pit
over 20 M down before she signaled for
the the team to pull her back out then
she told them what she had seen there
was something down there the entrance to
another location beneath all of the
bodies someone asked if there was any
sign of researcher singer Colin shook
her head face growing pale she hadn't
seen him down there he was gone agent
Collins was granted a temporary leave of
absence and a d-class
d272 was selected for further
exploration of the anomalous m grave he
was outfitted with a retractable harness
communication and video equipment as
well as a photo ionization detector a
Geer counter a basic survival kit a
firearm and ammunition d272 was then
lowered into the pit via a crane after
12 M of descent there was no longer any
visible light inside the pit and
d272 switched on his headlamp a few
moments later d217 to began tugging on
the tether demanding to be lowered more
quickly when asked why he insisted
someone just touched my back at 18 M
down
d272 began to feel a sense of confusion
and dizziness unable to tell which
direction he was going at this point in
the pit gravity had inverted forcing
d272 to climb upward in order to
continue moving down as he crossed into
another world there was Daylight visible
here again as
d272 climbed out from within the mass of
bodies there he found a seemingly
identical version of the town of TBI he
was instructed to take soil samples and
the monitoring researcher noticed
something odd on the video feed there
were marks in the dirt around the grave
that appeared to have been made by
fingers pulling across the ground they
decided not to relay this to
d272 after the soil samples came up
normal
d272 was instructed to walk to a nearby
Cottage and look for any sign of the
missing researcher singer he knocked on
the door and with no answer let himself
in he saw no one inside and began to
walk through in the bedroom on the wall
there was a charcoal sketch of a
humanoid figure holding a staff of some
kind command ordered him to approach the
drawing but he protested saying he felt
incredibly uncomfortable looking at it
he relented and be began to approach but
as he did the quality of the video feed
began to degrade until it was filled
with static d272 was then permitted to
leave the cottage and further explore
this copycat Village while walking
further into the village d272 spotted a
work boot on the ground he picked it up
and found it was a match for the one
researcher singer had been wearing he
followed the path to another house the
door of which was wide open he walked
ins side to find signs of a struggle an
overturned couch and table a hole in the
wall the broken pieces of a lamp
scattered on the floor the kitchen was
just as much of a mess and as he
investigated it further he found a pool
of blood on the floor with significant
blood splatter on the walls and counter
it looked like someone had been attacked
with a weapon likely a knife indeed as
he looked
d272 spotted a Butcher's Block with only
one empty slot the one that should have
held a meat cleaver the investigation
led him to a locked door covered in
scratches he broke it down and nearly
fell down the stairs into the darkened
basement instructed to head down into
the basement
d272 switched on his headlamp drew his
weapon and descended into the darkness
the basement was empty except for a
bloody meat cleaver and a piece of pant
leg caught inside an exhaust fence
leading out of the house the pants
resembled those worn by singer before
his fall
d272 peered into the vent for a closer
look but was startled by the sight of
something scuttling out of sight
whatever it was it was fleshy and it was
not something he cared to see more of
d272 continued on his expedition walking
North and away from the town limits of
TBI somehow in spite of this he wound
back up at the sou side where he had
emerged from the pit but something was
different there were no bodies no open
grave and no tethered harness that he
had taken off when he climbed out he was
trapped the harness had not been
retracted so where had it gone command
could not determine its exact location
but proposed that
d272 had entered another anomalous area
and was not in fact back where he
started he was instructed to follow the
road rode back retracing his steps until
he wound up at the pit again as he
walked he commented that he had not yet
seen a single living thing in this place
then as he heard the sound of rustling
leaves he turned toward it to find the
corpse of an sccp 783 victim he turned
back to continue on his way only to see
another victim sprawled across the road
he drew his weapon then listening as the
rustling began again he spun around to
look at the behind him and found that it
had stretched longer growing closer to
him behind him the other body began to
snap as well he turned to fire his
weapon and saw that this other body had
stretched its neck its head at eye level
only a meter away from his own face he
fired several rounds but the corpse did
not respond ignoring orders d272 took
off running into the woods leaving the
road behind he stopped to catch his
breath sat down and reloaded his firearm
after eating a quick M and informing
command of his whereabouts he set back
off on his journey through the forest
after 14 minutes of walking he began to
feel movement under the ground short
sharp burst of motion reverberating
through the Earth he could also hear a
thumping sound coming from beneath him
on the video feed command saw what
appeared to be a silver birch tree
lifting out of sight then dropping down
back into to the forest shaking the
ground on impact
d272 was instructed to approach the
object as command quickly realized that
this was no tree as he approached
another similar object landed near him
he fired his weapon at it and blood
began to dribble from the wound a scream
ringing out high above him not knowing
what else to do he ran as fast as he
could begging for help from command for
someone to do something to get him out
out of there as D 2172 ran out of the
forest making his way back to town
another one of the long pale objects
knocked him onto his back he looked up
now able to see what it was without the
trees in his way when he saw it he
couldn't help but scream it was
researcher singer or at least it had
once been researcher singer he had
become something else something
Unthinkable his body was up in the sky
balancing on enormous impossibly long
fingers the creature that had once been
singer shrieked lifting a finger and
preparing to bring it down on
d272 he fired several shots but none hit
so again he turned and ran he reached
the main road and kept running tasting
bile in the back of his throat and
feeling his lungs begin to burn he
couldn't stop if he stopped the creature
would grab him in those awful fingers
and he didn't want to think about what
would happen next then he saw it the pit
the bodies his way out he sprinted
toward the pit almost there when a
screech rang out and a massive finger
knocked him aside the video feed was
lost with only the sound of d272
screaming and running away after this
d272 was considered lost an attending
researcher Dr Peterson ordered that the
team pull his harness back out agent
Collins protested saying they had no
evidence of d272 is death Peterson
relented and they waited for the signal
eventually it came two tugs on the
tether
d272 asking to be pulled out but when
they pulled the tether an empty harness
emerged something was caught on it
holding it in the pit as the team tried
to draw it out it was
d272 hand gripping the harness as hard
as as it could the harness Broke Free
from his grasp and his hand flailed
searching for his chance at Escape
another d-class rushed to help grabbing
a hold of 2172 hand another declass
joined in along with Dr Lafayette and
private a and the group worked together
to pull the flaing man from the pit only
as they pulled they realized that only
his arm had come out and it was
continuing to come more and more and
more of his arm stretching out to 3 m in
length bending and snapping at gruesome
angles they were too late after all he
was already gone despondent the group
released him and he sank back down into
the pit with the rest there is currently
no way for the foundation to remove the
Crooked Man from TMI for containment
instead they must maintain a strong
presence in the town monitoring the
community via a temporary site five this
area includes two houses and a building
near the local hospital their Foundation
officers will track any signs of SCP
7783 activity as well as continue to
research the entity's nature and any
potential weaknesses it may have in the
event that SCP 783 becomes active all of
its victims must be removed from the
site of the attack their bodies must be
incinerated and they will be added to
the case file for now there is not much
anyone can do but wait and see because
the cycle isn't broken yet it's only a
matter of time the crooked man is coming
back to do his crooked Deeds be thankful
the foundation knows what everybody
needs if you want to stay yourself
protect your muscle flesh and Bone then
you'd better heed this warning don't
stay home at night alone working at the
SCP Foundation can really get your
appetite tight going after spending a
rough shift monitoring the acid levels
in SCP 682s tank or performing the
rituals necessary to keep the devour of
worlds on the other side of SCP
2317 sometimes you just need a quick
snack to hold you over before you return
to the old grind problem is at the SCP
Foundation even the break room can be
perilous Dr Dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on site anymore but this presents
its own series of issues you only have
an hour for lunch and obviously you
can't order in due to security issues
also if you're eating off site you have
even less time to finish your lunch
because the site you're currently
stationed at is relatively remote we're
talking at least a half hour round trip
to actually get to somewhere so you're
going to need your food fast and when it
comes to fast food few eies are as
prolific as the golden arches McDonald's
and just to clarify this video is not
sponsored we're going to tell you about
a horrifying anomalous secret that this
company really doesn't want you to know
about let's not think about that just
yet though your stomach is rumbling and
you need that quarter pounder so bad
that even being trapped in the red
reality with Dr Scranton couldn't stop
you from getting it when you finally
arrive you buy your typical order a
quarter pounder with french fries a
coffee and a McFlurry you see Dr clef a
few tables down enjoying a box of
chicken nuggets and ketchup but decide
not to engage at as you sit and enjoy
your meager little lunch knowing you'll
probably be coordinating the cleaning
efforts of scp1 73's containment chamber
by the end of the day your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling
happy the current mascot for McDonald's
Happy Meals you can't help but shudder
you've seen some pretty horrific things
on the job nightmarish things you fear
no monster but that thing it scares you
those big soulless eyes the wide gaping
moth full of two white teeth it's
diabolical sneakers no child should ever
have to look at that you can't help but
wonder whatever happened to Ronald
McDonald the hamburger happy clown that
Shield fast food to you throughout your
childhood what is he up to now well we
have an answer for you but I'll warn you
you may not be quite as eager to suck
down a Big Mac and a DI of coke after
hearing this Ronald McDonald first
introduced as the company's mascot in
1963 had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the
company in the mid-2010s for a greater
focus on the nasty little box homunculus
you can thank John Wayne gasy Pennywise
and those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor Stateside Ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the Ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in North
America a monster was born a horrific
Abomination birthed from a cow like many
have theorized about SCP 058 the Heart
of Darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and Scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seemingly grafted to its feet fresh from
birth the creature was huge with a
disportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seemed to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remained completely dormant
most of the time while most people would
have screamed run away or called the
police the farmers at this particular
cattle farm decided to let it ride and
see how this whole night nightmarish
Affair played out that sense of
curiosity and patience would soon pay
off for them financially it didn't take
long for the creature to grow the bigger
it got the more it looked like a giant
mutant version of McDonald's iconic
mascot Ronald McDonald and this wasn't
just a coincidence either it turned out
that this monster was somehow
intrinsically linked to the McDonald's
brand because once a day the creature
would horrifically unhinge its jaw and
begin to barf out a huge quantity of
mcdonal ond's food and we're not talking
about raw materials that are converted
into McDonald's food the creature later
dubbed SCP
5962 vomited out fully packaged
McDonald's products the owners of this
clownish monster had just hit the
lottery so to speak while the
particulars of the deal are unclear they
somehow contacted a representative of
the McDonald's corporation based in
China in exchange for presumably a large
sum of money Chinese McDonald's
operatives covertly entered the country
and shephered the now massive creature
over to a McDonald's owned Warehouse in
Beijing by this point it was around 4 M
tall and weighed over 5 tons it was kept
inside a cage and housed at some cost
but soon enough the creature was paying
for itself as we mentioned before the
creature constantly secreted fry oil
which was siphoned off for use in
preparing McDonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of packaged
food that it vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the Chinese branch of
McDonald's incredibly financially
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course SCP 5962 had
become McDonald's China's best kept
secret but of course no secret this
Sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse were paid or threatened for
their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the purpose of preparing
McDonald's food across the country
there'd be be no way you wouldn't speak
to somebody about it nobody knows whose
loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around Beijing about a huge clown
inside of a McDonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the SCP Foundation finally
took notice two agents Jonathan Jang and
George nagasa were dispatched to perform
an infiltration Mission along with a
team of backup Personnel they entered
the warehouse apprehending any employees
they found as they and their
reinforcements reach reach the northern
side of the facility they found SCP 5962
with a heavy collar around its neck
chained to the ground like King Kong as
McDonald's employees wielded away carts
of package food neither of the attending
agents were fans of McDonald's food but
even then just seeing this horrible
display was enough to make them feel
nauseous the creature was taken and
contained by the SCP Foundation who
conducted a number of tests on it they
found that the monster had no real
internal organs save for 20 seven
interconnected stomachs genetically they
also found that the creature was far
more cow than human the same could sadly
not be said for the food that SCP 5962
was vomiting out seriously if you were
already feeling a little queasy from all
this we need to warn you that this is
the part where things get really vile
let's talk about what the McDonald's
food barfed up by SCP 5962 was actually
made out of as we mentioned earlier the
food exuded by the creature was
genetically human with DNA often
matching that of people who are alive
and in no way affected by this anomalous
process tests have indicated that
certain foods condiments and beverages
correspond to more specific types of
bodily tissue and liquid for example the
bacon and Fries were shown to be
cartilage and ligaments the bread turned
out to be made from hair nails and skin
the coffee was liquefied fecal matter
the chicken nuggets were made from
fingers ovaries and testes even the
water was a mix of saline and sweat and
of course the ice cream was comprised of
Poss bone marrow feces and nasal mucus
depending on the flavor you get the idea
we'll stop listing off examples before
you lose your lunch but rest assured all
of the food produced by SCP 5962 was
made of human organic matter when the
SCP Foundation interviewed Mr Chen the
manager of the facility where SCP 5962
was being held before his amnestic
treatment he seemed incredibly casual
about the whole thing as far as he was
concerned the food still tasted exactly
the same as regular McDonald's food and
it didn't appear to have any adverse
health effects beyond what you could
expect from regular non-anomalous fast
food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughter houses
where the meat is typically obtained Mr
Chen also contested that SCP 5962 wasn't
all that dangerous either the only time
it ever performed an offensive action
was when an employee of the enemy fast
food franchise Burger King entered its
vicinity the creature vomited a stream
of hot coffee at the corporate
interloper like a fire H until he left
suggesting that it does have some kind
of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonald's company but still other than
this isolated incident the creature has
never even displayed sentience it was a
big strange clownish McDonald's food
dispenser when questioned about the
origins of SCP
5962 Mr Chen once again underplayed the
strangeness of the situation saying that
he'd heard rumors the farm that sold him
SC SCP 5962 had also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the US the farm which we can only assume
is situated right next to a radioactive
waste dump was also behind SCP
4158 also known as Big Charlie this
giant omnivorous and seemingly Immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been
birthed from a non-anomalous cow sold to
the Butcher Block slaughterhouse it
looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues leading
to the employees at the slaughterhouse
trying to put the creature out of its
misery however ever no matter how hard
they tried to kill the monster it just
wouldn't die its bones were pretty much
indestructible and no matter how much of
its flesh was cut off it just kept
growing back causing no ill effects to
the creature itself eventually The
Slaughterhouse workers tried cooking and
eating the meat leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as
non-anomalous meat much like the Chinese
McDonald's and as CP
5962 the workers had just hit the
lottery with big Charlie as long as they
kept feeding the monster which ate
everything from bricks to other
non-anomalous cows it provided a pretty
much Limitless supply of meat giving
them unprecedented economic prosperity
in other words big Charlie was a literal
Cash Cow Jeff fine the slaughterhouse
director even started worshiping big
Charlie as a kind of demigod by drinking
his blood he believed that big Charlie
was a savior sent to lift them all out
of their struggle and Desperation sadly
for them the SCP Foundation sent them
right back back when big Charlie escaped
their slaughterhouse and Foundation
field agents found secured and contained
it it was a sad day for the Butcher
Block so what have we learned today
whether you're in the US OFA or the
Chinese Heartland if you're chowing down
on fast food you really have no idea
where it came from I mean we kind of
knew that already but for all we know
the food you're enjoying could have just
been vomited up by a giant fat clown or
cut from the Flesh of a mutated cow just
think about that next time you're
enjoying a Burger but hey let's be
honest with ourselves we'll all probably
still eat it despite the fact that it
covers the majority of our planet
surface we know remarkably little about
the oceans well we know how to navigate
them and how to send boats from one
continent to another the surface of the
water is usually a calm safe place where
all you expect to encounter are other
humans and the occasional storm what's
below the surface is another story
scientists estimate that we've only
explored maybe five % of the world's
oceans and what lies in them on top of
that they estimate that we've only
encountered and cataloged 10% of marine
life that means that 95% of the ocean is
unexplored and Untouched by humans and
that 90% of the ocean species have never
even been seen by humans it makes you
think just what kind of stuff is down
there it could be anything even mundane
ocean life can be deeply strange and
bizarre there are sharks that live live
for over 300 years Blind Fish that only
hunt by smell jellyfish that are reborn
whenever they die if normal ocean life
is this terrifying and explanation
defying what kinds of anomalies could
the oceans we swim and fish in be
playing host to one such anomaly is SCP
835 but before we get started SCP 835 is
an old old file it's one of the earliest
in the foundation database in fact like
many of the foundations earliest
documents it's been heavily redacted and
expunged to the point where large blocks
of the text are missing not to mention
the fact that it's been locked behind a
Content filter but SCP 835 is unique not
because it's been expunged and redacted
but because it's had them lifted
versions of the file and its addendum
that are cleared of the redactions have
been Declassified and released by order
of 05-11 to all viewers for some reason
whatever was so secret about this file
known longer applies but before we take
a look at the Declassified documentation
let's look at the old version to get an
idea of what exactly we're dealing with
here the attached image for SCP 835 is
to put it simply gross it's what appears
to be some kind of bone or muscular
growth underwater a bit like Coral but
much more organic and flesh-like in
shape the growth is mostly white and
brown but large sections are grown over
with what looks like some kind of black
mold spores it's large to almost the
size of a person's chest and seems to
continue out of frame the caption is
simply still image from recording 81
it's not even clear if this growth
whatever it is is SCP 835 or not
continuing on to the file the object
class is ker and the special containment
procedures are lengthier than most
articles and very detailed they explain
that as CP 835 must constantly be
monitored and checked to see if it's
growing or expanding in the event that
it becomes hostile to Foundation
Personnel something known only as
suppression tactic A- A6 is to be
activated until it ceases any hostile
action the anomaly has to be contained
in the open ocean rather than moved to a
water tank or such because of the highly
aggressive response of scp-835 to
confinement for any length of time so
whatever it is it's alive it's expanding
and growing and seems capable of knowing
when it's being placed into containment
and responding angrily it's not only
sentient it's intelligent and aware they
go on to say that SCP 835s waste has to
be immediately collected and contained
and that it is to be fed two times every
day though what exactly is going to be
fed to it is redacted in this version of
the file it can also be moved to a new
location up to two times a year but only
if the current location can't support it
anymore and if the move has been
approved by the site directors on top of
that Personnel have to stay away from
SCP 835 at least 15 ft they also need to
have safety harnesses attached to
winches on the boat if anyone so much as
touches scp-835 all of the winches will
activate and rapidly yank all the divers
back to the boat from there suppression
tactic A- A6 is again instituted but
there is another line if a staff member
touches SCP 835 and is captured by it
then the anomaly is to be monitored
around Around the Clock until the
subject has been released very ominous
containment procedures this Predator if
it is a predator has a penchant for
consuming people and needs to be avoided
at all costs but if someone is caught it
releases them after a while the
description of the document clears some
things up scp-835 is a mass of polyps or
tissue growths that resemble Coral it's
huge and heavy though its full weight is
again redacted and the individual p are
also huge over a meter long much longer
than any known Coral species the Central
Mass is oval and has a huge 3 m long PP
on each side of it but can't move or
budge because of its huge weight instead
it uses huge tentacles extending from
the Pops to dig into the ground and
anchor it in place against the ocean
currents these are the same tentacles
that are used for feeding and are
covered in a sticky glue-like adhesive
they're not just long and strong either
test s have recorded them damaging
stainless steel plating and speaking of
plating SCP 8835 is covered in it not
steel but some kind of organic Coral
that's much harder than steel and
couldn't be broken by even Diamond drill
bits all the foundation could get were
small samples and if that wasn't bad
enough the foundation's positive that
SCP 835 is growing like the containment
procedure suggested and it's growing
fast up to 50 lb in a single day if it's
left uninterrupted but it can't be
stopped it reacts to certain chemicals
that make it close up like an oyster and
stop growing for 24 hours at a time
based on that the foundation's been able
to develop and use a chemical cocktail
to force it to Halt the aforementioned
suppression tactic A- A6 however the
results of testing it have been redacted
in case the anomaly wasn't disgusting
enough it also vomits that's right every
couple of hours it expels a large mass
of some liquidy sludge material from
both sides so to speak after sample
testing the scientists realized it
really is vomit well part of it the
substance is mostly semidigested food
feal material and Sean but also contains
life samples of biohazardous viruses
bacteria and parasites some that the
foundation haven't even encountered
before as CP 835 one of these bacteria
is a big problem for containing SCP 835
but exactly why that is is unfortunately
expunged from the file as well between
the lethal witch's brew of dangerous
diseases and the diamond hard shell that
covers SCP 8835s internal guts it is
nearly impossible to neutralize or even
damage it even if you do crack the shell
the diseased fluid inside would leak out
and infect you full of diseases in
seconds wow that's kind of crazy yeah so
CP 835 is a really really really nasty
customer I mean just by looks alone it's
easy to tell 835 is probably nothing to
mess with but a simple visual of the
thing in your line of sight does no
justice in showing how actually
dangerous and disgusting it really is if
you try to break it you get your immune
system overrun by a cocktail of diseases
if it doesn't manage to eat you first
the document has one addendum an after
action report by a member of mobile task
force Zeta 9 the notorious mole rats the
mole rats are one of the foundation's
most elite teams of Special Operation
troops like all mtfs they have a very
specific specialization one thing they
do better than anyone else in the world
for Zeta 9 its cramped spaces the task
force is highly trained in exploring
dangerous constricted areas especially
those that lie underground from
Subterranean caves to endless staircases
and basement labyrinths the mole rats
are the best of of the best at getting
in and getting out the mobile task force
Zeta 9 had been performing an
investigation on SCP 835 albeit when it
was considerably smaller only a meager 4
tons and it hadn't formed a second big
pup yet just like usual four members of
the mole rats were chosen to begin the
investigation equipped with underwater
isolation suits to ward off any
biological threats Lieutenant C
sergeants l and m and Corporal h a
rookie team member who was training with
them and was ordered to only observe
they took a small underwater drone with
them one that would come in very handy
at first scp-835 didn't act hostile or
aggressive towards the members of the
team in fact it even allowed members to
swim up to it and touch it without
reacting they couldn't even tell if it
was alive or not so they sent the Drone
to approach the huge PP on the North
side while they went around to the small
entrance on the other side of the rock
Corporal H was told to remain there and
make sure that the power cable to the
Drone didn't break off or snap
everything seemed calm suddenly the
drone's claw arm jerked back having
gotten stuck in something and began
thrashing around not wanting to wake the
creature Corporal H moved forward and
tried to free the claw but then he
became trapped too the other members of
the team heard him on the radio
screaming for them to come and help him
and that he'd been grabbed by some
horrible tentacle thing that was
dragging him towards the pup that had
opened up into a mouth the the incident
left Lieutenant c a bit ruffled
afterward Jesus Christ I can't do this
he was just a kid it was his first
mission I should have kept my eye on him
after a moment she composes herself and
begins to explain what happened the
anomaly grabbed Corporal H having fooled
the rest of us what we thought was the
entrance to just some cave while the pup
on the North side was the real entrance
into SCP 835 the tentacles came out of
its smaller pops grabbed Corporal H and
began dragging him in while he thrashed
around and screamed the boat tried to
pull in the winch but from all the
activity the line snapped in two
Corporal H was pulled inside as CP A35
and eaten the lieutenant explains that
she swam over and hooked herself to his
outstretched hand when the boat began
witching her up she said just as she
assured him that they're going to be
fine and that she's not letting go her
lines snapped and they were both
suddenly pulled inside she breaks for a
moment before describing the inside as
like a wet pulsing tube like how
intestines look on colonoscopies they
were both steadily being pulled in by
the muscle contractions what doctors
call peristalsis the way your body moves
food down your throat and through your
intestines the only reason they weren't
dissolved or crushed was because of the
isolation suits they were wearing but
they still couldn't move corpal H had
vomited in his suit but they were both
alive the lieutenant Thinking Fast
figured out that if they were moving
through its body they would come out on
the other end in 72 hours they had air
and water in the suits but little
battery and if the heat went out they
would freeze to death she quickly killed
all of the lights and Power in both of
their suits to the minimum except the
helmet lights so they could make sure
that the other was still alive the pair
stayed like that for a whole day with
absolutely nothing but the creatures
digestion and their own breathing after
a while the corporal's face was visible
he looked tired and scared she said that
13 hours in the kid started talking and
babbling she calmed him down and they
both slept for a bit but were rudely
awoken by falling into the stomach of
the creature they both fell out into a
small chamber filled with liquid and
barely a moment later their suits began
to melt in the stomach acid she yelled
and they both ran for a hole in the wall
SCP 835 sphincter at this point it was
very clear that they made it into the
intestine and it was worse than the
stomach I'm sure you can imagine how
horrifying it must have be to be in the
mix of this creature's fecal waste
disgusted and vomiting the Corporal and
Lieutenant picked each other up knowing
that they were making strides of this
terrible ordeal but they reached a dead
stop the creature's rectal hole was
tightly shut blocking their escape they
decided to wait knowing that it would
have to excrete eventually and after an
undeterminate amount of time I mean any
time spent in something's intestines
waiting to be pooped out is too much
time the lieutenant was shot out into
the sea but without the Corporal she is
obviously angry telling the agents to do
something expunged before declaring she
needs a drink and to sleep what a
horrifying story but there are gaps
let's take a look at the uncensored
documentation for scp-835 first let's go
back to the containment procedures what
scp-835 is to be fed is explained any
kind of local fish but higher level
mammals if it goes into a rage State
including humans in fact it seems to
calm down when digesting higher mammals
maybe it's developed a taste for human
flesh and in any case the feeding should
never happen without heavy supervision
next the results of Performing tests on
the samples of SCP 835 the foundation
was able to get scp-835 is no normal
Coral it seems to be made from what can
only be described as basic human
biological components the hard outer
shell is super dense calcium like your
bones but hundreds of times harder the
pops are covered with the same kind of
enamel that you'd find on your teeth and
the fleshy muscle that the tentacles are
made of is mostly mutated tongue cells
the creature seems to have most of the
biological systems we have but they've
all degraded or mutated into almost
unrecognizability except the digestive
and reproductive systems which are
highly Advanced 835 I5 the bacteria
unique to the anomaly is explained it's
how SCP 835 reproduces when vertebrates
are infected with it they will undergo a
variety of symptoms gaining huge amounts
of weight despite always being hungry
for things that normally can't be eaten
like wood and raw meat their skin will
harden and form polyps across its
surface their biological systems will
slowly stop working and they'll become
aggressive and then they will
drastically reduce an intelligence and
motion except for the desire to enter
the sea sound familiar that's right
being infected by it turns the victim
into another scp-835 instance with no
way to cure it and just like it seems
SCP 835 is still somewhat aware and
intelligent at one point this thing was
a normal human just in case that's not
horrible enough the after Action Report
has also been thoroughly Declassified
let's take another look to see the real
full story of what happened to
Lieutenant C and Corporal H inside SCP
835 the first reveals when Corporal H
was being pulled into the pup he was
screaming and crying begging for help oh
God it's eating me I I don't want to die
command tells Lieutenant C to abort the
mission but she refuses to leave one of
her Men Behind holding his hand while
hooking them together then the line
snapped and they were pulled in just as
they were escaping the stomach and right
as she hit the sphincter she realized
the walls of the stomach were lined with
human faces screaming and wailing and
begging to be killed she pulled her
weapon out and began firing into them
and she would have melted if Corporal H
hadn't pushed her through in the
intestine the Corporal began to complain
of a rancid smell she checked and
realized he had a breach in his suit but
quickly patched it but it was too late
she looked at his face and it was
growing pules already they burst
spraying blood and he begged to be put
out of his misery but when the
lieutenant shot her gun at him all It
produced were empty clicks she had
wasted all the ammo on the crying
stomach faces suddenly tentacles burst
through the corporal's face plate and
simultaneously pinned theut tenant down
she managed to flip what had been the
Corporal over and wrestle with what was
left of him before the sphincter into
the stomach where his body began to melt
in the acid but before it did she saw
the corporal's face smiling and said he
loved her before he died then she felt a
burst of energy and was shot through the
exit with a troubled gleam in her ey she
stands there telling her story to the
agent she takes a second to gain some
strength and then says I didn't make it
out intact my suit was breached and I
didn't even realize until I took it off
and saw the rash on my skin realizing
she's going to die she suddenly puts the
room she's in on lockdown in orders the
debriefing agent to evacuate everyone
else aboard immediately just before she
kills the feed she makes one request
that the foundation not try to
decontaminate the small boat just to
abandon ship and Scuttle it on top of
SCP 835 on top of the Corporal that way
they can be together in some kind of
sick resting place SCP 835 is the
horrible tale of things that can go
wrong at the foundation and two people
doing their best in a brutal situation
but with the modern containment
protocols and ensuring people know what
happened to the pair the foundation can
ensure no one ends up like the
lieutenant and the Corporal again d181
was used to being picked as a test
subject for the various dangerous and
downright terrifying experiments and lab
work the SCP Foundation hadn't performed
form at secure facility site 32 he'd
been working for the organization for
nearly 5 years and he considered every
day he was alive of blessing and you
would too if you were a d-class
Personnel while no one's too sure on the
exact methods the sccp foundation uses
to recruit its d-class personnel there
are a few prevalent rumors most of which
you've surely heard before death row
prisoners taken into custody by the
foundation to be unwilling Lab Rats
ordinary people that Society wouldn't
miss that were kidnapped off the streets
or sometimes just volunteers though
we're not sure who in their right mind
would willingly volunteer for one of the
most degrading dangerous positions in
the entire Foundation the truth about
d-class is that every site does it
differently and the foundation is well
aware of the controversy among its
Personnel that comes with recruiting and
using d-class Personnel he some sites
don't even have d-class citing their use
as inhumane but at site 32 things were
ordinary and d181 was one of the many
d-class personnel drafted into the
foundation via the United States prison
system day in and day out d181 would
have to perform tests and experiments
most of which he knew next to nothing
about thankfully for him d181 had two
benefits that made his stay at site 32 a
little easier first there was the fact
that site 32 was a low priority facility
it was located far away from any major
population centers and overall lacked
the expensive funding some of the larger
sites had the anomalies contained there
were still pretty dangerous but due to
the lack of available funding most of
what the foundation was able to afford
at site 32 was regulated to safe and
uclid class objects now as we all know
object class has nothing to do with
danger levels and instead is based on
the difficulty the foundation has
containing a certain object more than
anything else so when a site such as
site 32 is underfunded due to being less
of a priority to the larger organization
they're typically only going to be
containing the bare minimum in terms of
expenses that means less expensive
containment and less elaborate objects
for d181 to work with it wasn't a
guarantee of safety as nothing ever is
in the SCP Foundation but it was at
least beneficial to have an
understanding of what's going on in the
various experiments d181 had to perform
throughout the day the second thing d181
appreciated about site 32 was a little
less conventional the entire facility
was staffed by women with the exception
of male Personnel being used for testing
purposes the reason for this is due to a
very specific detail about today's
anomaly which we'll get back to but it
was something that d181 never took for
granted of course d181 was an absolute
buffoon when it came to dating and
relations between testing subjects and
researchers were discouraged and in some
cases forbidden however he never gave up
hopes that he might be able to Now find
a girlfriend while living in a building
that was less than 1% male in population
it is important that we state that d181
was always respectful to women and never
stepped out of line which as far as DCL
classes go makes him toptier boyfriend
material maybe there's hope for him
someday so long as he survives the
deadly Daily Grind of being on the
lowest rung of the foundation while
these two things kept d181 as happy as
someone could be while essentially being
enslaved to the foundation there was a
lot to be unhappy about in his position
first there was the General danger that
came with testing with anomalies every
day where anything and everything could
go wrong and your safety was never
guaranteed then there were the dreams
most of the time d1's waking State felt
like a dream so that meant the image his
brain showed him at night were extra
weird the horrors and Oddities that d181
witnessed during the day always came
back to haunt him at night whether it
was a stack of talking bowling balls
attacking him in the grocery store or a
teacup that made his skin invert itself
every time he drank it the SCP objects
d181 worked with always cropped up in
his dreams at night and they always
seemed to be worse d181 asked the other
d-class Personnel stationed at the site
if they had strange dreams too and most
of them agreed that they experienced
them as well apparently working for the
foundation fired up the imagination in
an extra special way that seeped into
nighttime when d11 would ideally be
receiving some well-deserved sleep from
the strangeness of the day but one dream
was bothering d181 significantly more
than usual it was a recurring one
happening again and again every few
nights the same series of events playing
out over and over again the strangest
part about it was that it didn't feel
like a dream at all d81 would be laying
in his bunk inside site 32s d-class
Barracks desperately trying to fall
asleep eventually he would but he
wouldn't realize it d181 would feel like
he was asleep but he could still see the
barracks around him except he couldn't
move at all d181 was experiencing a form
of sleep paralysis a phenomenon during
falling asleep or Waking Up where a
person is unable to move or speak
hallucinations during sleep paralysis
are common but the whole experience
typically only lasts a few minutes for
d181 it lasted a lot longer and he was
aware the entire time so d181 would be
laying down in his bunk trying to fall
asleep when he would suddenly become
unable to move then from across the room
he'd see the door to the bar open d181
knew that the barracks were only
accessible to the upper ranking
personnel and they never came around
first d181 saw a large cylinder move
itself slightly into the room then the
figure it was attached to waddled its
way through the door a giant fabric doll
so big that it could barely fit itself
into the door if d11 could scream he
would he recognized the figure as an
instance of SCP
2386 one of the anomalies he was working
on the doll walked slow and heavy trying
to not collapse over its own weight it
was made of pink fabric with its face
stitched together with thread forming a
Sly smile and two buttons for eyes it
was terrifying what was even worse were
the two pairs of wings on the doll's
back like the kinds you'd see on a
butterfly or a moth the brilliant
patterns looked like they were made of
cloth sewn to a pair of ordinary insect
wings and completing the doll's
Patchwork appearance the insect doll
combination stumbled towards d181 moving
across the Barrack slowly and nearly
falling over several times the creeping
Terror of the doll's slow Advance only
made d181 try to move more but he
couldn't he was completely paralyzed and
subject to whatever the doll was about
to do to him eventually the doll made it
close to d1's Bunk standing over the bed
and staring at d181 with its lifeless
button eye face it just stood there
staring d181 was sweating with tears in
his eyes he tried to scream again but
nothing came out and then to make
matters worse the Barrack's door opened
again and what made its way through
shook d181 to his very core it was
another doll even bigger than the other
one and behind it was another doll and
then another four dolls in total made
their way into the room and stumbled
over to D1 81's bed they continued to
stare crowding around the sleeping
declass like he was a television set and
their favorite show was about to begin
just when d181 thought it couldn't get
any worse the dolls extended their
stubby felted hands over his face all
four of them moving in unison and then
they stopped and d181 heard their voices
well not their voices exactly but voices
nonetheless high pitched barely human
childish voices started whispering to
him they weren't coming from the dolls
but they could talk d181 was positive
this is what they'd sound like you're
doing such a great job you're the
nation's greatest ass we love you anyone
anyone we love
you all of these seemingly innocuous
phrases were things said to d81 while he
was rounded by the giant dolls on paper
they sound encouraging but the context
of the situation and the way they were
said made them anything but and this
would continue for what seemed like
hours with the dolls crowding d181 and
speaking to him in his paralyzed State
shouting the most deceptively kind
things possible over and over again all
while d11 was aware the entire time but
before he would wake from this awful
dream one of the instances would lift
their stubby hand forward directly
hovering over d1's arm and the doll's
appendage would caress him squeezing and
playing with his arm like it were a toy
by morning when d181 awoke from his
dream he felt like he was never asleep
in the first place and that he could
remember every agonizing second of the
past night's experience this would
continue almost every other night as
soon as d181 would fall asleep the doll
dream would occur again as as soon as he
woke up he feel like he got next to No
Sleep the night before it was draining
him and inhibiting d181 from performing
his duties accordingly one day during
testing d181 fell asleep in the middle
of an experiment and dropped an
important component to the object he was
working with which nearly set the entire
facility on fire after that d181 knew
that something had to change d181
recognized the dolls they were instances
of scp2 386 which he had worked with
previously in fact it was the
experiments with SCP 2386 that injured
d181 on his right arm causing an
infectious spot to crop up what caused
this and what exactly is SCP 2386 we'll
get to all of that soon enough but we
need to focus on the dreams it was 3
weeks into the dreams 3 weeks since d181
was injured during testing and 3 weeks
since d181 had a good night sleep he met
with Dr Shaw the head researcher in
charge of SCP 2386 experimentation and
someone who worked with d181 many times
Dr Shaw and d181 sat down and prepared
an interview she began good morning d181
you say you've been having recurring
dreams d181 shuffled in his seat a bit
yeah hi HW ever since I got this thing
it wasn't that bad at first d181 of
course was talking about the red spot on
his arm Shaw asked him to explain the
dreams and d11 did he explained how he
would be in his bunk feeling almost
awake but not quite when giant versions
of SCP 2386 would make their way into
the room they'd gather around his bed
and stare at him shouting things and
caressing his infected spot Dr Shaw
listened intently d181 was clearly
shaken up from relaying the experience
to another person he continued barely
able to pulled himself together you see
something had changed the night before
d181 spoke to Dr Shaw for the first time
the dream was altered actually last
night they did something different
another one came in it had something
with it looked like a baby one was all
wrapped up in this white cloth they said
something about wanting to show me what
I was working towards they pulled back
the cloth over its head and it was a A
Bug's head look me right the heck up a
baby was with a bug's head was
definitely strange imagery but Dr Shaw
was unsure what it all could mean she
knew SCP 2386 were insect-like and with
the way d181 infection was looking her
brain began concocting a strange but
potentially true theory one that wasn't
looking good for
d181 but before we get into that let's
talk about what SCP 2386 really is
they're known among Foundation Personnel
at site 32 as Pink Ladies and they are a
diminutive species that outwardly
resembles Patchwork dolls made of
traditional fabric think that creepy
raggedy an doll your grandmother has but
10 times more degraded a whole lot more
pink and straight up insectoid in nature
they're not as big as the ones in d181
dream but they're actually as scary with
stitched on faces and a pair of moth
Wings on their backs in fact the actual
SCP 2386 instances range from only 7 to
9 cm tall autopsies on dead instances of
SCP 2386 showed resemblances to human
botflies and silk worms two species of
insects that are absolutely nasty it is
terrifying to imagine something so
outwardly cuddly could look so downright
ugly on the inside but that's what SCP
2386 are but don't try hugging them
either their cotton fiber exoskeleton is
as durable as it is gross and they're
not the kind of cuddly doll you'd want
to take to bed at night in the wild SCP
2386 are found in hives resembling
similarly patterned seat cushions big
mounds of cloth host to tons of these
tiny Terrors with the biggest Hive the
foundation ever came across being the
size of a large sofa these hives are
commonly found near suburban
environments and sometimes even inside
occupied housing imagine coming home to
find a brand new sofa inside your house
and then realizing that it's actually
home to thousands of SCP 23 386
instances when SCP 2386 leaves their
colonies it is primarily to feed on
smaller insects and seek out hosts for
Reproductive purposes despite their cute
but gross appearances SCP 2386 become
hostile if approached by males of any
species and will Target them accordingly
that's why site 32 only employs male
Personnel for testing purposes as soon
as they're within range of a male
subject SCP 2386 will outstretch one of
its pendentes and extend a pair of
scissor-like Claws from it before
swarming the mail this is what happened
to d181 which resulted in the red
infected spot on his arm conversely
female subjects in the presence of SCP
2386 are treated entirely differently
with the instances caring for them
presenting them with small gifts and
attempting to play with them during the
spring and summer seasons SCP 2386 will
enter their mating season and cease
their hostilities to towards males
instead they'll treat them with the same
level of kindness they do with females
but this kindness is just a front when
given the opportunity SCP 2386 will
slice a small incision into the male
subject and pump them full of about 30
to 65 eggs underneath their skin within
24 hours the incised area will resemble
pattern cloth and genetic tests reveal
it to be composed of the same material
as SCP 2386 is hives in the weeks that
follow this area will spread across the
subject's body and eventually it will
open to reveal fully grown adult
instances of SCP
2386 who burst from the patchwork skin
Dr Shaw recognized that this is what was
happening to d181 and immediately got
him to site 32s medical ward d181 was
strapped down to the table and tried not
to freak out over what he knew was about
to happen the dreams were acting as a
warning and SCP 2386 was clear CLE
looking forward to having d181 bear the
next generation of insect dolls
thankfully Dr Shaw caught the infection
before the patchwork skin was able to
fully take root meaning that the eggs
underneath d181 skin were premature
thankfully there was still time surgery
was carried out immediately and the
doctors weren't surprised to discover a
colony of premature SCP 2386 eggs
underneath d1's arm they were removed
from the body and thrown into storage
for further research purpos es d181
after waking up from the surgery thanked
Dr Shaw at least now he wouldn't have to
deal with those horrible dreams and the
stinging swollen sensation underneath
his arm unfortunately he was still a
d-class Personnel working for the
foundation and would have many more
intense experiences after this one but
d1's gratefulness would soon subside
within a few hours d181 began to ask Dr
Shaw if he could see SCP 2386 is
enclosure he spent the past few weeks
absolutely terrified of the species but
for whatever reason he felt like he had
unfinished business with the anomalies
he wanted to see them again Dr Shaw
became suspicious and understandably
denied d181 entrance from the enclosure
but this wasn't enough d181 became
violent and tried to force himself into
the containment chamber he needed to see
them he couldn't explain why but he felt
incomplete eventually d181 was subdued
and returned to his quarters but his
symptoms continued throughout the weeks
he was depressed and frequently made
reference to SCP 2386 as being lost or
unrightfully taken away from him to Dr
Shaw what was happening was clear d181
had been affected mentally upon
receiving the SCP 2386 eggs this was a
safety mechanism induced by the anomaly
in case of birthing complications so
d181 would feel compelled to receive
another batch of eggs into his body if
the first batch was lost or damaged it
was disgusting and Shaw was positive it
would subside after a few more weeks but
what kept her up at night wasn't the
same dreams d181 had or the terror of
SCP
2386 it was the image of d181 scared and
out of his mind clawing that containment
chamber door begging to be used as a
host for SCP 2386 is next batch of eggs
when you see some of the monst ERS and
entities they try to contain it's easy
to think of the SCP Foundation as the
good guys and granted When You observe
the magnitude of threats like the
Scarlet King it's hard for anyone to not
look like a downright moral Paragon in
comparison but the foundation aren't
always knights in shining armor
sometimes they themselves have committed
horrific atrocities in order to keep
their Supernatural subjects under wraps
and keep the rest of us safe from
anomalous Terror nowhere is that had
more clear than a deadly incident that
occurred in 2010 the foundation had been
aware of the slow bur sloth for decades
and many believe that the entity has
existed for as long as human beings have
consumed visual media movies TV web
pages and even print media like books
and magazines are vulnerable technically
speaking the name SCP
2774 refers to whatever visual medium is
currently holding the true entity known
as SCP 27
74-a thankfully SCP
2774 has never made it onto the internet
where it could do truly catastrophic
damage but the foundation has prepared
for that possibility they've invented a
software program WebCrawler A3 g32
designed to constantly monitor all forms
of online visual media for an appearance
of SCP 2774 d a so what is SCP
2774 What could could possibly be so
scary that even a picture of it leaking
onto the internet could potentially lead
to the collapse of human civilization
simply put SCP 2774 daa is this image of
an unknown humanoid entity in a bizarre
sloth costume while this picture may
seem harmless that's only because it's
black and white and any red or green
Hues have been neutralized from the
image anyone who isn't red green
colorblind and somehow accidentally sees
the true version of SCP
2774 has a fate far worse than death in
store for them this is the same fate
that would befall almost the entire
population of the northern Canadian town
of Harper Ridge in 2010 the residents of
this small Township were waking up and
going about their morning some were
getting ready for work others enjoying a
leisurely breakfast in front of the
television set all of those affected had
unknowingly made the deadly mistake of
watching the local news that morning
while the anchor droned on about some
Local Economic statistics and delivered
a dry advertisement for an upcoming town
Festival The Familiar image of something
in a sloth costume appeared briefly on
the set behind him most of the Harper
Ridge residents who viewed the broadcast
didn't even notice the sloth but in that
fateful instant almost every single one
of them was doomed the slowburn sloth
doesn't always affect everyone who sees
it Foundation scientists have found that
it generally only affects 40% of people
exposed to it and doesn't affect those
suffering from color blindness at all
however one of the more frightening
details about the sloth which is
classified as a mimetic image SCP for
its ability to spread and appear
randomly almost anywhere is that it
grows more powerful and more contagious
with every living victim it affects
after claiming a significant number of
new victims say from a small Canadian
Town SCP 2774 daa's infection rate can
rise to as high as 60% or beyond the
residents of Harper Ridge made their own
Predator deadlier without even knowing
it at a nearby Foundation facility units
were already mobilizing it was too late
for those who had already seen the
slowburn sloth but others could
potentially be saved if the situation
was contained quickly in addition to the
WebCrawler constantly monitoring the
internet the SCP Foundation also had a
huge number of dedicated teams scanning
broadcasts worldwide for potential
instances of scp2 7 74-a exposure when
one of these teams detected the sloth's
presence in Harper's ridge's morning
newscast and found that upwards of 4,000
civilians had already been exposed they
knew there was no time to waste back in
Harper Ridge the situation was already
deteriorating a few hours had passed
since the broadcast and those who were
exposed were beginning to experience
strange symptoms already first it was a
sense of tiredness and lethargy then an
unusual heaviness to their body as
though they were experiencing sudden
extreme muscle fatigue people exposed to
SCP 2774 daa also experienced clouded
cognition even thinking straight became
a real struggle it was at this point
that the true effects of witnessing the
slowburn sloth began to take hold around
6 hours after initial exposure little by
little the infected lost all cognitive
functions and higher level
decision-making abilities their bodies
still acted out basic movements very
slowly seemingly just as a result of
muscle memory but they had no control
over what was going on they became
essentially living zombies trapped in
their own bodies and only dimly aware of
it this horrifying experience was
completely consistent with prior
Foundation Research into the effects of
viewing SCP 2774 daa and in a Twist
almost crer than permanent zombification
victims of the slowburn sloth are
randomly allocated around 150 seconds of
Lucidity every 24 hours before being
forced back into their zombified state
just as 4,000 of Harper ridge's
residents were beginning to experience
these effects all local communication
channels to the town were cut off by the
foundation well equipped teams of mobile
task force operators began arriving on
the scene shortly after accompanied by a
number of containment units in the form
of buses and trucks lucky for them the
zombified victims of the slowburn sloth
were incredibly docile and compliant by
Nature shepher all 4,000 of them into
the containment units were almost like
working with cattle some non-infected
local residents attempted to protest the
sudden Abduction of their zombified
loved ones these residents were subdued
and either had their memories wiped with
Foundation amnestics or were terminated
on site like with almost any conceivable
situation the SCP Foundation already had
measures in place for a mass exposure
event like this all in all a mere 4000
was still on on the low end of the
potential infection scale the 4,000
victims were secretly taken to site 116
a foundation testing site under the
direction of Dr Martin and his second in
command Dr Clara Chong there they hadd
already been pursuing research on
approximately 2400 infected subjects
from prior incidents including
Foundation Personnel who were
accidentally infected during the
monitoring process thus far it seemed
that the condition caused by witnessing
the slowburn sloth was incurable and
with 60 400 known living victims
situated at site 116 SCP 2774 daa was at
an unprecedented level of power all site
Personnel were instructed to proceed
with caution and carefully observe the
behavior of their new test subjects Dr
Chong spearheaded the majority of the
Hands-On Research into the infected
residence of Harper Ridge and observed
some interesting phenomenon in the
victim's behavioral patterns as the
condition escalated the infected
subjects even in their largely zombified
state developed an almost fanatically
religious obsession with the image of
the slow burned sloth when left to their
own devices they would create Idols of
SCP 2774 daa these included amateur
sculptures made of hoarded garbage
images drawn of the sloth with any
materials they could get their hands on
or even writing obsessively about the
sloth Dr Chung speculated that this
Behavior was perhaps an act of
appeasement on the victim's part hoping
to somehow saate the slowburn sloth and
lessen its effects on them through
worship however she would later find out
that the truth of the matter was far
more disturbing initially due to their
largely docile States the subjects
imprisoned in site 116 were given a
relatively Long Leash the subjects were
even allocated 2 hours a day for social
interaction with fellow subjects at meal
times and during a designated
recreational period during these times
the subjects would often trade their
slowburn sloth Effigies with one another
however Dr Chung revoked the social
interaction periods and began confining
the subjects to separate euklid class
containment cells when violence began to
break out between them it became clear
that during their 150c periods of
Lucidity every 24 hours the subjects
would become extremely distressed
agitated and even aggressive Dr Chung
also ordered any Idols from trash
sculptures to Doodles and notes on
fragmented scraps of paper to be
destroyed immediately at its new
increased power the foundation became
concerned learn that SCP 2774 daa May
develop the power to manifest through
these images no meaningful Headway was
being made on a cure for the condition
so something needed to be done before
the situation got out of hand in hopes
of gaining a better understanding of the
internal processes of slowburn sloth
victims Dr Chung decided to conduct a
series of interviews with the subjects
under her care two such subjects subject
0866 AKA David and subject 7444 AKA CLA
were isolated for a 24-hour period in
hopes of catching them during their
daily 150 seconds of Lucidity doct Chung
and the foundation found the results of
these two interviews to be as
Illuminating as they were utterly
terrifying when David regained Lucidity
he was in a state of extreme agitation
and showed an unsettling fixation on the
clock in the site 116 interview room
under direct questioning from Dr Chong
he revealed that slowburn sloth victims
are fully aware of what's happening
during their zombified periods he
compared the sensation to being a
passenger trapped and bound in a vehicle
over which they have no control however
in this state victims are also unable to
hold a thought consistently for longer
than 5 Seconds this leaves them in an
almost constant state of disorientation
worse still David describes that the
victims are subjected to near constant
hallucinations of the original sloth
image guiding and controlling their
movements almost like a puppeteer thanks
to the the clock David was aware of when
his 150 seconds of Lucidity were about
to come to an end after apologizing for
what he was about to do David lunged at
Dr Chung causing a guard present in the
interview room to shoot him dead for Dr
Chung's protection Dr Chung's interview
with Clare echoed the same sentiment
during her 150 seconds of Lucidity Clare
first begged to be killed before
divulging further details about the
zombification state she would describe
hallucinations of the slowburn sloth
stalking her constantly and controlling
her movements in some cases the sloth
would force her to open her eyes all
night while it stands next to her bed
and screams at her as cla's 150 seconds
of Lucidity ended and she became
non-responsive Dr Chung put in a request
for Claire's termination a request that
was fulfilled 3 days later the third
interview with subject
9225 also known as Jason showed that SCP
2774 daa appeared to be manually
starting the fights between the subjects
perhaps even for its own sadistic
Amusement he also stated before the
interview's conclusion that the image of
the sloth and his hallucinations was
becoming darker and more tangible almost
like it was becoming a real physical
being which was an unprecedented
phenomenon Dr Chung was for the first
time in a while truly afraid it seemed
by all accounts that SCP 2774 daa's
power was growing considerably as a
result of its huge number of active
victims its infection rate had likely
risen well above 40% and its ability to
manifest would likely be on the rise too
if the slowburn sloth was able to
manifest on a national broadcast
Millions would be infected to truly
apocalyptic results Dr Chong only saw
one solution that might curtail the
entity's growing power but it wouldn't
be pretty she devised a procedure known
as procedure XX j9 as part of the
procedure procedure additional staff
were brought into site 116 immediately
the real purpose of the plan was
revealed shortly afterward to reduce the
number of active subjects on site from
6,400 to a mere 200 in hopes of reducing
risk over the next several days staff at
site 116 engaged in the gruesome task of
executing around 6,200 infected subjects
via lethal injection this was an
atrocity so horrific even by SCP
Foundation standards that Dr Chong Al
allowed the parties involved to use
Class A amnestics to erase their
memories of being involved in the mass
murder of site 116 subjects in the
aftermath of the call the foundation did
report a decrease in SCP 2774 dasa's
manifestations so Dr Chung's procedure
did indeed work just at a heavy human
toll the tragic incident of the 2010
Harper Ridge SCP 2774 Containment Breach
is a grim reminder of just how far the
SCP Foundation is is willing to go to do
their job and a reminder to be careful
where you look because some images have
a much more lasting impact than others
imagine if you could predict the future
not perfectly mind you but with enough
accuracy that brilliant enough Minds say
the best and brightest of the SCP
Foundation could plausibly reverse
engineer the main determinative factors
that caused a certain timeline to form
imagine if through carefully studying
these determinative factors the
foundation could carefully shape the
future into one that's more favorable
for the human race than all the
Alternatives the preferred option if you
will would this not be advantageous your
next question is a very natural one
given the circumstances how does one
predict the future in such a manner well
the answer is uncomplicated but that
doesn't by any means make it easy you go
there spend a few months looking around
and then come back to report your
findings that's right folks we're not
talking psychics and sear here prepare
to expand your mind and please don't
worry if it all gets a little timey wiy
because SCP 2003 is the SCP foundation's
selfmade time machine even most of the
staff at the SCP Foundation itself don't
know much about SCP 2003 given the
highly sensitive nature of the projects
surrounding it much like SCP 2000 is a
trump card securing our present in the
case of a catastrophic XK Class end of
the world scenario SCP 2003 is our
prophylactic for such a thing happening
in the foreseeable future what's far
more unique about SCP 2003 is that the
SCP Foundation created this Ace in the
Hole from scratch the SCP 2003 time
machine was invented over a 25-year
period by reverse engineering the
anomalous technology of three different
classified anomalies and retro fitting
them into our own nonanomalous framework
the massive machine is housed in armed
sight 47 a remote and well-guarded
facility disguised as an oil refinery
while extensive records of SCP 2003's
construction have been made by the
foundation and it stands to reason that
the machine could be reliably and
successfully reproduced in a different
context even the most intelligent
scientists taking part in the project
couldn't explain how or why it actually
operates in the words of another mad
inventor it just works the operating
principle of SCP 2003 are relatively
simple to understand it is able to break
the laws of the SpaceTime Continuum by
immediately transporting anything or
anyone placed in its Central chamber to
some point in the chronological future
the subjects transported forwards will
remain in this future for several months
before instantaneously being transported
back to the exact location they were
standing in the future in order to
prevent some kind of unfortunate
accident like phasing back halfway
through a wall and becoming unpleasant
Modern Art the foundation has
established a secure facility for
travelers to head and wait out the rest
of their time when their mission is
complete through extensive testing
including that which was performed under
the purview of project xn Shepard the
foundation has discovered a great deal
about the nature of time travel via SCP
2003 we'll outline the most crucial
caveats here so what happens next makes
a lot more sense to you after all if
time travel was easy everyone would do
it first as we alluded to earlier the
data collected by SCP 2003 on the nature
of the future is often unclear imprecise
and unreliable for example the data
collected from 2003 did provide
extremely useful in predicting and
preventing a massive security breach
over at site 19 in 1997 so naturally
when it predicted a devastating series
of earthquakes off the west coast of the
United States in 1999 an event that
several agents sent through SCP 2003
observed directly it came as a shock to
everyone when nothing happened the
foundation discovered following this
that all predictions needed to be
contextualized through heaps of metadata
for it to be of any real use in
predicting or preventing our specific
future the foundation also discovered
that certain individuals had a strangely
disproportionate effect on the unfolding
of future events let's say for example
as CP 20 3 discovers that a new type of
nuclear weapon will be invented in 2028
and quickly adopted by a number of
leading Nations by 2030 and by 2035
tensions will rise Sabres will Rattle
and this nuclear weapon will be used on
mass to destroy human society as we know
it naturally in order to prevent this
the foundation might see to it that
certain groups of nuclear scientists
certain generals and certain world
leaders get liquidated and yet another
trip into the future shows that this
massive nuclear war was not not averted
but why because it just so happens that
this event was inexplicably tied to the
birth of a little boy named James
Hoskins in Saskatoon circuit 2025
despite little Jimmy Hoskins seemingly
having nothing to do with the actual
development of the technology seeing as
he's only 10 years old when the bombs
start falling the foundation scientists
working under project xn Shepard keep a
database of all these highly
determinative individuals also known as
magnifier individual idual so they can
keep tabs on how they're affecting any
future timelines speaking of future
timelines we're afraid to tell you that
this penultimate caveat isn't exactly a
pleasant one there are few to any
cohesive future timelines where Humanity
survives long term bummer right the
foundation calls these loose timelines
determinative sets and in the majority
of them human civilization collapses all
humans die and in some cases the Earth
becomes completely inhabitable to all
forms of life the foundation is
currently seeking a more optimistic
option through controlled manipulations
of the Casual stream in our time but
currently all we have is the preferred
option option xn and if you're someone
who would jump at the chance to travel
into the future and take a gander at all
the wondrous or terrifying sites there's
actually one pretty major caveat of SCP
2003 that we've been playing rather
close to the chest Foundation tests
found out that the time travel process
via SCP 2003 is extremely damaging to
plant and animal tissue rather than just
going on a wacky time travel Adventure
like Doctor Who or Austin Powers it'd be
a little more like stepping into a giant
microwave while dressed in a spacit made
of aluminum foil you're going to die a
horrible death but there is one silver
lining well maybe not silver from your
perspective probably more like peer the
foundation has discovered a way to
viably send human adjacent subjects
through time with SCP 2003 without
instantaneous death we just can't
promise that you're going to like it you
see the one kind of organic tissue that
seems to survive the SCP 2003 time
travel process is the human brain and
nervous system due to the highly
controlled nature of project xn Shepard
the foundation can't just send in DCL
classes to do the job they instead use
actual agents though mostly ones who are
nearing or Beyond retirement or are
suffering from from a terminal illness
these agents are dosed on a course of
anti-anxiety
anti-depressant and anticho chemotherapy
to toughen their minds for the horrors
to come though the exact nature of these
Horrors is kept secret from them until
it's already happened you may be
familiar with one of the foundation's
most well-known front companies Boston
Dynamics as well as one of their most
famous products the robotic quadrupedal
probe known as Big Dog well in order to
send a sentient being through time
without them being completely destroyed
by a SCP 2003 the agent brain and
nervous system are entirely removed from
their body and transported into the body
of a modified big dog still think it'd
be fun to time travel heyy don't look so
nervous for everyone who agrees to be
part of an SCP 2003 Mission and survives
you'll get one hell of a pension or at
least your family will if that's any
consolation now that you understand all
this let's come clean about this
mysterious project xn Shepherd we've
been alluding to throughout the video it
all started with a letter to the heads
of the SCP 2003 research project from
057 a member of the legendary 05 Council
that instructs the foundation in all
that it does the letter read up until
this point all attempts at Future
intervention using SCP 2003 have been
Limited in scope and scattershot in
nature I've seen the wisdom in this
approach it is informed by painstaking
contingency planning and risk benefit
evaluation Z past 18 months of reports
however have promised if we are bold
enough to seize the initiative we may
have found a way out here theice so z a
a price as you well know consider this
note an official change in policy as of
today all efforts at intervention are
now aimed at bringing about and
preserving xn designated magnifier
individuals Associated this xn are to be
protected from undue interference at the
expense of all other priorities in
particular Nang must be allowed to die
in the manner most observations have
predicted for her if anything at all
changes in that regard make it happen I
trust that you're familiar enough is the
rest of the determinative sets to
understand why we're going this way so
in short of all the potential timelines
057 wants the researchers assigned to
SCP 2003 to ensure that the timeline xn
is the one that actually comes to be
seeing as it's preferable to the
alternative
hence project xn Shephard you're
probably wondering what happens in
Timeline xn that makes it the most
desirable outcome possible well things
continue as normal everything from
anomalous activity to social unrest to
environmental factors stay pretty much
the same as time goes on until 2349 when
a giant 22 km asteroid strikes the Earth
and wipes out the majority of humanity
in an instant following this the world
becomes unfit for human habitation and
don't look so glum you all be dead by
then well except Dr brigh sorry again
jack we at least get a nice three
centuries before we're wiped from the
cosmic table your next question is
probably if the preferred option has
Humanity being wiped out by a giant
asteroid in a little over 300 years what
are all the other ones aren't we
entitled to a multiple choice future if
we don't feel comfortable with being
completely annihilated by an asteroid
before we're even halfway to the year
3000 well we'll give you a little
tasting clatter of potential timelines
and you can take your pick there was the
narrowly avoided scenario XB where
things progressed in a similar fashion
to scenario xn except a massive gamma
ray burst from the Sun in April 2017
wiped out all life on Earth within 38
seconds then there's scenario XI where
the birth of an unnamed boy in
Turkmenistan combined with the election
of Sir William an whistle as prime
minister of New Zealand in 2049 leads to
a world destroying nuclear exchange
between Israel and greater Indonesia in
any attempts to stop it just make it
happen sooner or what about scenario xh
here A Deadly mutated form of influenza
causes the deaths of over a billion
people worldwide combating this threat
causes increased cooperation between
World governments that actually resulted
in a huge net Improvement for Global
Peace and quality of life it seems
unrealistic we know but SCP 2003 doesn't
lie however despite things going well
all known life on Earth just vanishes on
July 29th 2059 it's a hell of an
unpleasant twist after things start
going so well for once in scenario XO
the anomalous increases in frequency and
magnitude in 2037 this leads to a broken
masquerade scenario where the
foundation's web of secrecy collapses
and anomalous chaos Reigns across the
globe the foundation's members are
hunted and killed and World governments
attempting to weaponize the anomalous
leads to a new arms race that wipes out
all of humanity by 2048 or maybe
scenario X you is more your cup of tea
in this one the sun collapses leading to
Eternal darkness and massive temperature
drops inexplicably humans still survive
but are in a state of constant unmoving
Agony and maybe if you just really love
spiders you'll get a kick out of
scenario XX where a mysterious
pathogenic protus causes the majority of
humanity to fall in love with the
Brazilian wandering spider one of the
few spiders that pose an actual threat
to humans the diverting of all resources
meant to to keep humans alive to instead
breeding the spiders combined with many
many many many people being killed by
the resulting spiders leads to 6 billion
deaths in the early 2030s but hey you'll
get to see some pretty great spiders if
that's your thing I guess scenario xn is
hardly a picnic nobody likes the idea of
facing an Armageddon straight out of
Armageddon when that asteroid kills all
life on Earth in 300 years but while it
undeniably isn't perfect it may just be
the best option we've got H isn't the
future amazing Russell's Back was
pressed against the wall his shuttering
hands gripping the fire axe the low
emergency lighting filling the corridor
indicated the lockdown was still in
effect although that was simultaneously
a blessing and a curse sure it meant
that thing couldn't get out hopefully
but it also meant that Russell was stuck
in the wing of the facility with it he
had no idea if anyone else was left he
hadn't seen what had happened happened
to Carpenter maybe it got him or perhaps
he had managed to give it the slip at
the last second there was no way of
knowing for sure it had all started so
simply so innocently and with such Noble
intentions if he had known it would lead
to all this madness Russell would have
never put his name down on the request
form the SCP Foundation had been working
on a way to neutralize or cure SCP 610
for what felt like forever to one team
of scientists the infamously so-called
flesh that hates was a fascinating
organism it was a highly contagious
saric skin disease isolated entirely
within the small area of Siberia that on
its own wasn't enough to Peak the
interest of the research team led by Dr
Carpenter including his handpicked star
researchers Russell and David along with
their assistant clenon and Dr Boton an
expert on infectious diseases who had
recently joined their efforts to provide
his specialist knowledge
what did Captivate all of them however
was what SCP 610 did when it infected a
human being the disease would trigger
aggressive and uncontrollable mutations
within its infected and could virtually
rewrite their entire physiology in a
heartbeat the flesh that hates was
capable of transforming a person's body
into a horrifying fleshing mass of Limbs
and matter that barely resemble the
human being anymore and in addition the
infected individuals would retain some
level of awareness attacking any
uninfected person with extreme hostility
there had long been chatter amongst some
other research teams studying SC SCP 610
about devising a way to weaponize the
disease if they could somehow create a
variant that didn't turn people into
monsters or at least caused the fleshy
Abominations to die shortly after
mutation then the foundation or another
interested party could deploy the flesh
that hates as a biological weapon Dr
Carpenter had long abhor the idea in
instead searching for a way to
completely reverse the effects of an SCP
610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
hope researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried treating scp-610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr botton's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another
SCP Russell brought this hypothesis to
the rest of the research team and each
of them had suggestions for other
anomalies they could potentially Ed to
cure a subject of the flesh that hates
we could get SCP 049 to take a look at
the infected patient Clinton suggested
oh might work Carpenter mused although
even if he cills someone he might also
kill them he has his whole deal about
ridding the world of the pestilence
could prove to be a problem uh there's
always
682 David said dryy have the reptile eat
up all the SCP 610 infectees and voila
problem solved oh real helpful David
researcher Russell retorted and what are
we going to do when SCP 682 adapts to
the flesh you really want an infected
Immortal lizard on the loose Gentlemen
please Dr botton spoke up we're
forgetting one obvious option I propose
we submit a joint formal request to use
SCP 914 for this experiment unanimously
the group all agreed that this was the
best course of action SCP 914 or the
Clockworks was a giant machine with two
booths marked input and output although
the foundation still couldn't fully
comprehend exactly how as CP 914 seemed
to take any object placed within it and
disassemble recreate improve or destroy
the item depending on its current
setting there was one issue however a
prior failed experiment where in a
d-class was placed in SCP 914 had led to
some pretty disastrous consequences as a
result ever since no organic matter was
to be placed within the Clockworks a
rule that the team's experiment with the
flesh would breach still they pressed on
each of the five researchers signing
their request to utilize SCP 9914 before
it was submitted to the foundation hups
within hours the request was denied but
the team was determined that SCP 914
could be the key to solving the
foundation's long-standing issue with
SCP 610 Dr Carpenter repealed the
decision urging the hups to reconsider
he argued that this flouting of the no
organic matter rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the flesh
that hates after a few days of
consideration the request was finally
fatefully granted the team went to work
immediately requisitioning two test
subjects both of which had suffered SCP
610 infections and were horribly mutated
the pair of them were deemed a potential
Hazard to every member of foundation
staff on site and as a result the entire
wing of the facility where the
Clockworks was housed had to be
evacuated for safety dressed in
biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
prod to coax the first flesh specimen
into the input chamber of SCP 914 this
was the test run they wanted to see if
the Clockworks would actually be able to
affect those infected with a SCP 610 at
all plus they needed a fail safe just in
case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked clenon to set the Clockworks too
rough and with a click and were of its
numerous gears and Gyros SCP 914 came to
life instantly the infected test subject
was completely obliterated the setting
had reduced it to atoms disintegrating
it on such a microscopic level that
there was nothing left in the output
chamber the second infected creature
seemed to bristle with anger but didn't
attack or become aggressive as it too
was pted towards the Clockworks next
perhaps out of fear that their Theory
might might be wrong the team agreed to
set SCP 914 to its one:1 setting sure
enough the machine recreated another
instance of a specimen infected with the
flesh that hates replacing the previous
one we all know we're stalling
researcher David piped up let's do what
we came here for set the Clockworks to
course nervously receiving a nod from Dr
Carpenter Clinton stepped forward to
switch the dial on SCP 914 to the course
setting this was the primary reason the
team had all agreed to to use the
machine on a flesh specimen this setting
could disassemble any item placed in the
input Booth separating it into its base
components Boton had suggested the use
of SCP 914 based on the theory that if
it worked correctly the Clockworks could
extract the flesh that hates from its
infected host rendering them free of the
disease the machine made a colossal
amount of noise as clenon hurried back
to a safe distance with the others but
as it was powering up seconds from
activating Dr Carpenter noticed
something the color drained from his
face as he saw it none of the others had
noticed from a distance that the dial
hadn't been set to course instead it
pointed to very fine the highest
refinement setting 914 had what the hell
have you done Carpenter yelled at clenon
before the machine suddenly activated
would step free from the output Booth
stunned the researcher it was a man a
seemingly ordinary human who had
presumably been infected by a SCP 610
some time ago he stepped nervously out
of the machine looking confused for a
moment as a pair of foundation security
guards cautiously approached him we did
it Russell said in awe suddenly fleshy
tendrils burst forth from the man's arms
latching on to the approaching guards
they screamed in agony their bodies
melting become a bloody misshapen mass
that stayed attached to the humanoid
creature at the center it was like they
became a part of it the guards arms and
legs forming additional limbs as their
forms were reconstituted and repurposed
as part of a monster that was now
crawling on its six legs towards the
research team in a blind panic the group
scrambled for the entrance the head of
the infected man splitting open down the
middle opening up into a wide snapping
pair of Jaws panting hard as he ran his
breath fogging up the clear face plate
of The Biohazard suit Russell ran
through the door hearing someone close
behind he stopped for a moment looking
back to see the creature on the other
side of the door starting to spill
through the door frame like a liquid
running faster around a corner Russell
came to another halt in the common area
a third security guard following just
before a thick Steel security door came
slamming down sealing the creature on
the other side the other door didn't
hold it what good is that going to do
researcher David yelled more to the
point Dr Carpenter said turning and
marching towards clenon he launched a
furious punch at the assistant knocking
him to the floor why did you set 914 to
very fine clenon the enraged doctor
shouted you're the one who Unleashed
that abom mintion you maniac what
Clinton replied fearfully trembling I I
didn't I swear I didn't it said course
I'm sure of it you expect us to believe
that was a mistake gentlemen we need to
focus on the situation at hand the
security officer interjected regardless
of who's responsible we need to inform
the foundation hups there's an emergency
lockdown Russell replied it would have
triggered the moment the SCP 610
specimen got free you've trapped us with
a monster clenon Dr Carpenter spat hold
on researcher David spoke up wasn't it
botton's idea to use 914 in the first
place the common area fell silent as
everyone turned to look at Dr Boton did
you plan for this doc David pushed Boton
chuckled need I remind you my friends
that we all agreed to use the Clockworks
did we not all of our names are on the
request he answered besides accusing me
David that's rather Rich coming from you
what's that supposed to mean the
researcher fired back beckoning his
finger Boton encouraged the rest of the
team to follow him across the common
area to where a row of lockers stood
each door bearing one of their names he
gestured to the one labeled David go on
botton added shooting him a dirty look
David barged past the disease expert and
opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leatherbound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying SC SCP 610
the researchers all knew a text on
sarcasm when they saw one it had been
long known that the flesh that hates was
often described in texts revered by
saric Cults who worshiped death Decay
and disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a sarst
carpenter asked the fury in his voice
already elevating no I'm not researcher
David protested I've never seen that
before it was in your locker the doctor
yelled you're one of those cannibal
cultists this was your plan to refine
the flesh for your Twisted death
worshipping religion it certainly seems
that way Boton interjected after all
research of David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even you
David pointed at the doctor you planted
this in my locker you're here a sarcast
clenon repeated in a nervous stammer you
made me turn the dial to very fun you
made that thing of fear you made me your
accomplice anger tears streamed down his
face Clinton's hand reached for the
security officer's gun and went to draw
planning to shoot David on the spot but
as he went to pull the weapon from the
guard's holster it wouldn't budge it was
then that assistant clenon stared in
horror at his hand his fingers had fused
to the guard's leg the officer gave a
twisted grin as his torso burst open
tendrils of Flesh latching on to clenon
and assimilating him just like it had
done before the flesh creature broke
down its victim's body making it a new
part of itself a grotesque mass of Limbs
and bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomachs turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell Heard a Voice whisper behind him
he turned to see Boton looking at the
SCP 610 creature and smiling researcher
David was the closest and the creature
lunged at him pulling his leg out from
under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching skin tearing and
Bones snapping as he became part of it a
new set of Limbs added to the monster Dr
Carpenter went to try and pull him free
but it was already too late and he
stepped back knowing that if he touched
it he would be infected too the sound of
running caught Russell's attention and
he spotted botton making a break for it
grabbing Dr Carpenter by the sleeve the
researcher pulled him in the same
direction partly running away from the
flesh as it assimilated David and partly
chasing ing the saric savitur the pair
of them quickly caught up to Boton
leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he weeed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare Upon Us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but boton's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire axe for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the axe out of its case
while spoton and Carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lock down bot was saying they
need to let us out and
then he let out a blood curdling scream
mid-sentence as the ax blade wounded him
Russell pulled it back standing over the
doctor as he fell to the floor in agony
Russell have you lost your mind
Carpenter exclaimed no doctor he's the
cultist I have no idea how he tricked
clenon but that flesh creature exists
because of him the researcher answered
from the floor unable to move thanks to
his injury Dr botton began to laugh it
took me years to infiltrate the
foundation so much time waiting to gain
access to that blessed flesh he glutted
and now you've helped me to refine it to
create its ultimate form you want to
kill me go ahead Russell my life doesn't
matter for once that creature is free it
will bring about a new age of Flesh and
Gran carus IR will reward me for the
role I played in unleashing it David was
right Carpenter realized Buton you
you've planted that book on him to throw
us off doctor we need to think of
something researcher Russell interjected
a still in hand nobody knows more about
the flesh that hates than us there must
be a way to kill that thing otherwise if
it gets out of this lockdown it could
spread to everyone in the foundation
what about fire that's been effective
against 610 infectees before right yes
yes but the doctor desperately tried to
think this new being we've created he
created Russell argued looking at the
grimacing wounded Boton we cannot deny
the role we've all played in this
researcher Carpenter argued and we have
no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the flesh before its
refinement but we have to try sir the
researcher protested of course I agree
the sickening sound of a slithering
slick Mass was rapidly approaching still
laying on the floor in pain Dr botton
had been dragged to the middle of a
junction with Carpenter and Russell
hiding around either Corner suddenly
botton started hollering as the flesh
came into view practically calling it to
him oh look at you he exclaimed you're
better than I could have ever hoped for
looking down at him with the faces it
had collected the creature stamed one of
its disgusting appendages through Boton
drawing its body into its growing form I
am honored to give my life so that the
age of Flesh May begin the doctor said
weakly through the pain as he was
infected from around the corner
Carpenter had taken the saric text and
set its pages on fire with a cigarette
lighter turning to the creature he
hurled the mass of burning paper at it
hoping it would be enough fire to spread
to the flesh while it was assimilating
Boton who they had left there as bait
the fiery book collided with the
monstrosity as Russell peaked around the
corner he saw the flesh retreating from
the Flames boton's body now added to it
for a moment it seemed like the creature
was afraid of the fire but slowly it
drew nearer and nearer to the book with
ease it stamped down the Flames with
boton's leg dowsing the fire and
suffering no damage to it at all
gripping the axe in his hands Russell
went to charge the creature only to feel
something push him back Dr Carpenter had
stopped him run he yelled instantly
Russell turned and raced down the
corridor the sound of fleshy tentacles
whipping through the air he dared not
look back just in case the monster was
right behind him eventually he reached
another corner and slammed his back
against it hands shuddering as he held
on to the fire ax he had no idea what
had happened to Carpenter maybe it got
him or perhaps he had managed to give it
the slip at the last second Russell came
a hush voice from around the corner one
the researcher recognized he turned to
see Dr Carpenter approaching him
sneaking like he was trying to avoid
being heard I think I managed to give it
the slip the doctor whispered for a
second Russell backed up his hands
tightening around the ax handle this
might have looked like Dr Carpenter but
was it are you really you doctor he
asked of course I am Carpenter replied
you don't think that I'm not that
monstrosity Russell raised the axe
defensively only to notice the sadness
in the doctor's face unable to bring
himself to swing even to find out the
researcher lowered his weapon Carpenter
looked grateful come on let's get them
to lift this lock down he said I'm sure
an MTF can step in and take care of our
mistake as the pair of them cautiously
made their way towards one of the locked
doors Dr Carpenter reached out a hand to
place it on Russell's shoulder ever
since she was in high school Faith had
dreamed of moving out and finally
getting a place of her own it wasn't
that she didn't love her parents she did
but they were always around always
coming into her room without knocking
telling her when to go to bed when to
wake up not to eat dinner in front of
the TV in college she had some welcome
Independence but she had to live with
roommates again they were perfectly nice
people some of them she even considered
good friends but she hated having to
share her space having to come home from
a long day of classes and see someone
else's dishes piled up in the sink to
have someone else's mus music keeping
her awake at night to delay her morning
shower because someone else had gotten
there first so she was thrilled when a
few years after graduating she got a new
job at a marketing company that would
finally let her afford a place by
herself at last she could have some
peace some quiet and most importantly
some privacy Faith spent all day moving
furniture and unpacking boxes turning
the little apartment into a real home it
wasn't much just a main room she used
used as a bedroom and living room a
bathroom and a basic little kitchen but
it was all hers and all of the little
personal touches she'd put together
really made it feel like the place was
meant for her there was the orange couch
she'd picked up at a vintage store
downtown the coffee table she'd gotten
for free from her last roommate framed
pictures of her family and friends a bed
with Linens in her favorite color light
blue and lots and lots of potted plants
over time she would find even more
things things more little personal
touches to liven up the space now how to
celebrate her new home her gas wasn't on
yet so she couldn't cook anything but
that was the perfect excuse to order in
30 minutes or less later she was kicking
back on her couch with a large cheese
pizza watching a scary movie on her TV
no one would ask to switch it over to
the bachelor no one would take the last
slice while she was in the bathroom it
was perfect finally
A Little Piece of Heaven an introverts
Paradise as she finished her first meal
in the new place she felt her eyes
beginning to grow heavy the day of
strenuous unpacking catching up with her
body just as she was thinking about
calling it a night a pale-faced monster
appeared out of nowhere on screen
terrifying the movie's main character
and making Faith jump spilling her soda
all over the coffee table damn it she
groaned already she'd made a mess but
hey she tried to look on the Bri right
side it was yet another first to break
in the apartment she grabbed a kitchen
towel to mop up the soda and when she
returned to the main room she froze
there was something in the window
standing out against the darkness
outside at first she thought it was a
reflection a trick of the light but as
she slowly approached the window eyes
wide and hands trembling she got a
better look there was a face a little
difficult to make out as if it were
peering out of the Shadows but
unmistakable nonetheless it was pale
human vaguely resembling a strange man
with dark circles under his eyes and he
was looking right at her she didn't
scream she was too terrified to make a
sound she stared at the face for a long
moment waiting for it to do something
anything after several moments of the
tensest staring contest of her life she
blinked the face didn't budge you you
need to leave she finally spoke Sur
surprising herself as she did if you
don't get out of here I'm calling the
cops again the face did nothing do you
hear me her voice climbed in Pitch her
heart pounding against the inside of her
chest who was he what did he want she
became vaguely aware of the fact that
she couldn't see the rest of the man's
body just his face looking at her with a
neutral expression a look of vague
curiosity like someone watching a caged
animal at the zoo might have it was then
she remembered something that made her
blood run cold made the towel drop from
her hands as her stomach sank she lived
on the third floor her apartment had no
balcony no fire escape he could have
climbed up whatever was looking at her
through her window it was no ordinary
peeping Tom she couldn't say how long
she stared at the face its unblinking
eyes its inscrutable expression she
moved closer to the window step by step
until she was almost nose to noose with
the thing she couldn't think of it as a
person though it looked like one mostly
she should run screaming out the door
looking for some kind of help but what
would she say that there was a floating
face looking at her through the window
what if it was somehow all in her head
some sort of hallucination brought on by
exhaustion and the stress of the move
she raised a fist and following a
passive Instinct wrapped on the glass
she didn't know what she expected for it
to Blink to move to knock back to say
something but nothing happened it just
stayed there as if it were part of the
window itself Faith pulled the curtains
closed hiding the strange face from view
with any luck it would be gone in the
morning she had worked hard to get this
apartment and she would be damned if she
let some strange thing whatever it was
drive her out of her new home but as she
climbed into bed and pulled the covers
up to her chin she could still feel its
Gaze on her as if it could see through
the thick fabric of the curtains she
rolled over onto her side her back to
the window and tried her best to forget
about it to shake that horrible feeling
of being observed she lay there for
hours eyes open heart racing but finally
the exhaustion won and she Slipped Away
into sleep she didn't dream at all that
night it was as if she closed her eyes
and seconds later it was morning she
woke to the beep of her alarm feeling as
if she hadn't rested at all the first
thing she did was climb out of the bed
and go to the window carefully
tentatively she opened open the curtains
she let out a sigh of deep relief the
face was gone she must have imagined it
after all a bit concerning but as long
as it didn't happen again she wouldn't
have anything to worry about lack of
sleep does strange things to the mind
after all no longer plagued by the fear
of that strange face faith hopped into
the shower and let the worries of the
previous night wash away disappearing
down the drain she brushed her teeth
dried her hair did her makeup and
dressed for work after a banana and a
quick cup of coffee she was out the door
work was exceptionally busy that day and
it pushed any memory of the Oddity in
the window out of her mind entirely she
was even feeling good enough to accept
her friend's offer to grab a drink after
work they met up at a bar down the
street from her new place sharing
cocktails memories and a plate of onion
rings it was a perfect lovely evening by
the time she got home savoring the click
of the key in the lock as she let
herself into her quiet little Sanctuary
she had completely forgotten about the
unusual Apparition she swung the door
open and rushed to dump herself onto the
couch for a bit of TV before bed then
out of the corner of her eye she saw it
the face back in its previous Place
staring at her from the darkness outside
she gasped at the sight her scream
catching in her throat it was just as
she remembered it wait no something was
different what was it she clapped her
mouth in horror as she identified the
change it's expression was different
gone was the vaguely interested neutral
expression now it was smiling at her not
a pleasant smile not a warm friendly
smile a wicked smile twisted and cruel
it knew she was afraid that she'd been
hoping it was gone forever and it was
enjoying itself her hands were shaking
nervous sweat beating on her brow what
do you want from me she whispered
staring into its eyes they didn't move
but they glittered with delicious Glee
just the same what do you want from me
she repeated her voice rising to a shout
shut up her next door neighbor yelled
banging on the wall it's after midnight
she couldn't bring herself to respond
she had more important things to attend
to her stomach turned bile rising in her
throat with the face begun again in the
morning would it come back again at
night was the apartment haunted
possessed by a spectre doomed to reside
in her window forever was that why the
rent had been so affordable or maybe it
was her maybe this thing had been drawn
to her or maybe she was losing her mind
unaccustomed to living alone and her
sanity was slipping away she shivered at
the thought what was worse if the face
was all in her head or if it wasn't
rather than attempt to answer the
question gnawing at her she closed the
curtains out of sight out of mind she
thought she would have to keep the
curtain closed possibly forever it was
better than seeing that damned face
grinning that horrible grin but as she
tried to settle in for another restless
night she could feel its eyes boring
into her burning into her skull she had
never felt so uneasy before she prepared
for cockroaches for black mold and for
burglars but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered to herself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window window
go to work try to forget about the
window get home try desperately not to
think about the window she could always
feel it though as soon as the sun went
down though she kept the curtains closed
she knew it was there she thought about
checking to see what face it was making
this time but she couldn't bring herself
to look gradually her condition worsened
she woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood the
effect began to follow her out of the
apartment too far away from the fa's
dwelling she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing there
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon even her formerly
dreamless nights of sleep as fitful as
they had been became unsafe she would
toss and turn sweating through her
sheets as her subconscious was tormented
by chilling visions and terrible
nightmares she would dream of walking
down a long dark hallway that seemed to
go on forever and something coming up
behind her trying to grab her and drag
her away it would chase her wide dark
eyes and long long limbs grasping at her
as she ran and ran but never escaped
other times she would dream of being
locked in a damp basement chained to a
wall as the pale creature sat in a chair
across from her just watching waiting
for something though she didn't know
what every night another nightmare that
made her wake up screaming fighting off
invisible attackers after 2 weeks of
living in hell she decided to look out
the window window again she had to see
had to know that night when she opened
the curtains it was there mouth wide
open eyes glinting it was laughing at
her screw the deposit enough was enough
she wanted her home back she picked up
the heavy lamp on her bedside table
wound it up and threw it at the window
with all her might the glass shattered
little crystalline Shard sprang in every
direction as the lamp flew through the
air out the window and down to the
street below and just like that the face
was gone on she checked every other
window in place the little one in the
bathroom the people on her door but it
was nowhere to be found she was free her
knees gave out and she collapsed to the
floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living living the nightmare all over
again looking out to darkened window to
see an unwelcome Guest The Entity known
as SCP
965 SCP 965 is a phenomenon affecting
framed windows when it appears it
manifests in the shape of a shadowy face
belonging to a pale man staring in
through the window the details of the
man's face vary from person to person as
well as his apparent age and the
direction he is facing however all
reports point to the same figure at very
ious ages ranging from 10 to 55 the
foundation has attempted to use facial
recognition software to identify a
citizen matching the description of this
figure but so far no one has been found
SCP 965 will not appear in just any
window it will only manifest when the
lighting on the outside of the window
drops below illumination of five
candalas the lighting on the inside of
the window does not have any measurable
effect the face will only appear in the
confines of a completely assembled
window window frame though the window
does not necessarily need to be
installed anywhere it will only move
from one glass pane to another if its
original point of manifestation is
destroyed the face can be seen from an
outside vantage point though it has been
described by observers as looking away
into the room when SCP 965 first appears
to someone it produces feelings of
unease anxiety and lowr paranoia anyone
within the visual range of the affected
window will experience these feelings
even if the window is covered by
curtains or any other means any
individual that sleeps in an area
visible to SCP 965 is manifestation
point will begin to experience
difficulty sleeping suffering from
upsetting and disturbing dreams however
this is not the end point of the
entity's impact on those it appears to
at a point between 3 and 10 nights of
sleep after its initial appearance the
entity's facial expression will begin to
shift into a noticeable smile after the
shift the victim symptoms will become
phys physical as well as mental
including ulcers and intestinal bleeding
heartburn abdominal pain and even
vomiting blood this has been attributed
to the entity's influence on the human
body's reaction to heightened levels of
stress and fear the subjects that reach
the stage of exposure to SCP 965 begin
to see its face in Windows in their
dreams as well as spotting it in their
peripheral vision while going about
their Waking Life they begin to see the
face out of the corner of their eye even
when the affected window is is nowhere
in sight these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following or watching them
though the entity has never made a sound
and does not move while it is visible it
can disappear and reappear in different
poses it has also displayed notable
signs of sentience appearing
disappointed when it manifests in an
empty room and angry if it sees someone
who broke its previous window when
presented with one of the agents who
first brought it into custody The Entity
appeared frightened for the first time
testing involving SCP 965 involving the
destruction of its host window confirmed
that a multi- pained window might act as
multiple holding zones but significant
damage to its overall structure keeps it
from being a viable replacement in this
particular case the entity manifested in
a nearby experimentation chambers's
observation window which was promptly
destroyed in order to prevent any
potential breaches for a month following
this incident
The Entity manifested with noticeably
hostile facial expressions clearly
resentful of its treatment only one
other notable incident has occurred so
far during the course of SCP 965
containment by the SCP Foundation Dr L
the rest of her name has been redacted
from the official file was the head
researcher assigned to SCP 965 for
several months before she filed an
official request for transfer to a
different test subject she was beginning
to experience intrusive visions of SCP
96 5 and lingering feelings of paranoia
lasting long after she left the
foundation's site her symptoms were
consistent with those of someone who had
slept in the presence of the entity
though she swore up and down she had
never napped or slept at all in the
vicinity of the affected window she was
temporarily relieved of her duties and
provided with psychological care so far
no other instances of SCP 965 impacting
staff who have not slept in its presence
have been reported but this case set and
unsettling precedent the mental health
of anyone assigned to SCP 965 is to be
strictly monitored in case it expands
its influence again SCP 965 is contained
within a framed ready to install window
made up of six panes of clear glass or
other comparable material at a size of
at least 15 cm x 30 cm the window must
be kept in an environmentally controlled
storage facility capable of withstanding
earthquakes and other seismic activity
the window must be inspected at least
once a week in order to check the
Integrity of the material additionally
at least two identical framed windows
must be stored in the same facility in
separate Chambers with additional
insulation any Lighting in the
containment chamber should be kept at a
minimum of 130 Candelas at any time
Personnel are inside with the exception
of research and experimentation though
SCP 965 is currently contained the
foundation is unable to control its
movement should its current window be
destroyed therefore SCP 9965 is
classified as uid scopophobia is the
fear of being watched or looked at by
others those suffering from this fear
will often avoid Windows terrified of
who might be standing on the other side
staring in and keeping track of
everything they do even those of us
without scopophobia might find ourselves
feeling a prickle of dread while looking
out the window at night watching for a
shadowy figure or a ghastly face pressed
to the glass most of the time of course
there is no one there there it's just an
overactive imagination the lingering
effect of watching one too many scary
movies but eventually your luck might
just run out one night when the world
Falls quiet and you go to close the
curtains before you go to sleep just in
case you might just feel that someone is
right there on the other side of that
thin pane of glass staring at you with
wide unblinking eyes it won't ever come
inside but it isn't going anywhere and
as long as you are where it can see you
you will never know peace again Diego
had only just found his footing when it
gave out underneath him again crashing
to the ground he threw both arms over
his head just in time to protect his
skull from the rain of Boulders that
came down past him they grazed his arms
and Jarred painfully against his muscles
but it was better than having them hit
him in the head without a moment to
spare Diego got straight up to his feet
and continued running back down the
trail he had been trying to follow the
ground shifted and lurched in all
directions under him threatening to
throw off his balance at any moment
having lived in Chile his whole life he
had gotten used to earthquakes but he
had never been in the center of one like
this the problem was that the trail he
had been following to get up here was
disappearing fast as the dust swirled
into the air and boulders Landing all
around him he just had to keep running
in this direction and Hope for the best
there weren't any other options but
suddenly he found himself running uphill
stumbling forwards Diego tried
desperately to get his bearings he had
spent the previous 3 hours hiking up the
mountains so how was it that now that he
had turned around and gone back he was
still going uphill it was almost as if
the ground was changing shape beneath
him as he ran dust filled his lungs as
he tried to wipe it away from his
burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andy's
mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to prevent it what cruel and
inhumane measures would you take to have
such a threat or better yet how many
people would you kill to save the world
this debate is Raging right now as you
sit here and watch this video not among
the foundation but between two scps so
Grand in scale and so advanced in nature
that the foundation has no option but to
sit and listen as the pair debate what
to do with the human race SCP
468-1 was not difficult to discover once
it started moving in fact it was almost
impossible to ignore earthquakes have
been tearing across South America for
centuries destroying homes taking the
lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of scp4
468-1 as the creature raised its head
into the air Diego saw the head of a
serpent lifting several kilometers away
from him its body stretched and wound
its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of SCP
468-1 is hard to convey measuring over
500 km in length this serpent is longer
than most US states with a 20 km width
standing on the back of it quite
literally feels like standing on a
mountain range for context The Horizon
at sea level is about 4.8 km away so
multiply that by four and you'll get a
sense of just how wide this thing is
even small movements from this SCP are
enough to trigger continent wide
earthquakes with tremors being felt all
the way around the world upon the
initial discovery of this SCP the
foundation was enabl to determine why it
remains dormant for such long periods
and seems to only awaken sporadically
and for brief periods of time that was
until SCP
45682 was discovered it is little wonder
that the second serpent took so long to
be found its body is comprised almost
entirely of water sand algae and steam
it does not show up on Sonar scans and
is incredibly difficult to detect in the
water even visually its form is Loosely
defined while stormant with broadly
similar measurements to SCP
468-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pinchers Bottom Feeders grow
larger mouths and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even
extra hearts these marine animals seem
to undergo virtually no distress and are
free to exit and re-enter the scp's body
at any point initially SCP
45682 was believed to be the peaceful
one of the pair both serpents seemed to
become active at the same time while on
land SCP
468-1 would wreck havoc with magnitude 7
earthquakes in major metropolitan areas
the sea Serpent's function was less well
understood employing resonant
frequencies and vibrations this SCP was
able to give its watery body a distinct
form as it rose up from the ocean and
towered above the waves in order to
maintain its shape and control its
movements this SCP employed a huge
amount of energy however the foundation
quickly observed that it was rarely able
to maintain its form for very long as
soon as the sea serpent rose out of the
water its mountainous twin would begin
to move sending Tremors around the world
that disrupted the frequency needed for
sccp
45682 to remain animate exhausted and
unable to maintain a shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dorcy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dorcy suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each SCP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up up high in the Andes
Mountains specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great scps several early findings
stood out firstly SC SCP
468-1 appeared to have a very different
internal structure from its twin
researchers initially assumed that the
creature would be largely composed of
Earth minerals and rock as its exterior
appearance suggested however scans of
its body indicated the presence of what
can only be assumed to be artificially
created components great gears
resembling Clockwork structures and even
rudimentary circuitry were present
throughout the creature's body the
function or origin of these gears has
yet to be determined especially as there
is no evident way that their movement
corresponds to the autonomy and movement
of the serpent itself the far more
striking Discovery however came when the
SCP Foundation discovered a way to
communicate with the two beasts Ultra
lowf frequency waves capable of
traveling vast distances even light
years were discovered to be emitted from
the two Serpent's heads at intermittent
periods the foundation had to develop
some of the largest antenna ever created
to pick up these frequencies and
interpret the dat data coming through
them what they found were two twins
locked in a fierce debate about the fate
of humanity and the universe itself it
was only then that the motivations of
these two serpents started to make sense
in 2010 almost as soon as the foundation
was able to tap into the frequency they
were contacted directly by a SCP
468-1
funion I know that you can hear me I
will not apologize for my actions I know
that I am the reason that millions of
your kind face their demise I know your
pain and I feel it too but I shall never
apologize for it I simply ask you to
listen to myself and to my word cannot
be translated you are curious you can be
patient exercise that and you may one
day understand and listen the foundation
did efforts to contain or destroy the
two serpents were put on the back burner
instead Foundation agents prioritize
spreading disinformation across South
America and Beyond about the source of
these earthquakes the two serpents are
far too large and far too powerful to
overcome or contain instead the
foundation prioritized the use of
amnestic drugs disinformation and the
creation of Fringe conspiracy groups to
discredit any claims of the serpent
respective existences meanwhile some of
the most senior lead leadership figures
in the foundation were and still are
locked in a fierce debate as to what to
do with the twin serpents by listening
to the communication between the two
scps the foundation discovered that SCP
45682 is intent on wiping out the entire
human race the only thing that has
prevented it from being able to do so
thus far has been the existence of the
other serpent every time that SCP
45682 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base SCP
45682 came to the observation window to
look them in the eyes as it told them I
am sure you can see it how your world
dies a little bit more every day mostly
by your own hand no you poison the
oceans tame the rivers blacken the skies
you do not need angels of death to
destroy your world but there is
something else I see it in the bottom of
your eyes something
Unforgettable unconceivable ideas
cloaked in Madness and impossible colors
do you think I will let you drag the
rest of the world World down with
yourselves do you think I will leave
this world my world to Die In Flames it
sees your world and it comes in
fives since this Revelation the
foundation has poured countless hours
and resources into trying to identify a
cosmic threat for well over a decade
many of the smartest scientists the
world has to offer have looked to the
night sky scanning for this impossible
color this shroud of Madness but to no
avail some within the foundation believe
the serpent is lying trying to make up
an excuse to justify its genocide but
information from SCP
468-1 seems to confirm everyone's worse
fears your minds burn bright fion all of
humanity shines from this rock like a
candle in a dark room it sees you an
idea exists only because something
thought of it have you ever considered
how such terrible Concepts could have
been given form what kind of atrocious
mind could even think about it humans
cannot conceive the colorless green what
if you are playing into this creature's
hands there appears to be an underlying
implication that ideas are the source of
power somehow this colorless green this
unimaginable Cosmic threat seems to be a
monstrous idea incarnate but whose idea
Humanity's there is a deep lore that the
two serpents discuss with one another
one that makes little sense even to this
day to the foundation they talk of gods
and goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel
and gears and of the fives quite what
these creatures are if they are even
creatures at all is a mystery to the
foundation researchers have not
discovered a way of communicating back
with the two serpents directly attempts
to mimic their language or transmit
signals asking questions to them have
largely been ignored instead they
address humanity and the foundation as a
whole seeming to take the view of the
human race as being a collective hive
mind one that they are evidently able to
tap into the pairs seem uninterested in
informing us as to exactly what this
threat is or explaining who the gods and
goddesses are perhaps they assume we
know these things already or more likely
they believe that our Consciousness is
not yet capable of perceiving the scale
and depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names Tren is the
land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way Kai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains trenen
gave a short speech that served both as
encouragement and a terrible warning of
the darkness to come it is something I
like about you fion about Mankind well
it is easy to just take the simplest
path to just give up there will always
be some among you who refuse this path
who do the right thing maybe not all of
you are this strong but I can see it in
your methods those so-called containment
procedures there will always be someone
who stands up against the dark even if
it takes a thousand million years to
emerge Victorious maybe you can stop
thefe after all
ideas can be killed with better ideas
even if it takes a thousand million
years what was that a face just as
quickly as I'd glimpsed it it was gone
it was cold as death and twice as dark
in here seriously i' I'd never been
anywhere so dark it was more than just
the absence of light it was like walking
through thick black water only able to
see inches in front of my face things
move slower than they should have every
step I took further down towards some
unknowable destination the darker and
colder it got I found myself wondering
is this what dying feels like slipping
down further into nothingness step by
step through Darkness That Never Ends it
was a Stairway like Jacob's Ladder
except instead of up to heaven it was a
oneway trip straight down there was some
distant tiny woring noise that I
couldn't quite make out the way things
sound when you're drowning I didn't know
what possibility was scarier that the
steps just went on forever and I'd be
walking until my bones turned to dust or
that something would be at the bottom
waiting for me in the dark the deeper I
got the more I got this sense that the
ladder was true the way you can feel
yourself being watched or sense someone
standing behind you at evolutionary hold
over from when humans still took part in
the world of predators and prey and we
were not the Predators some part of us
is just built to know when true danger
is lurking nearby or down below patient
and hungry I could feel its malice
rising up the stairs towards me the way
people in a skyscraper Catching Fire can
feel the heat coming up from below and
know it's already too late for them for
the first time my eyes came into focus
and I made something out in the distance
when I realized what it was and worse
how strikingly familiar it was all I
could do was scream that's when I woke
up drenched in sweat and relieved to see
the darkness of the stairway replaced by
Bright Morning lights shin Shing in
through my bedroom window my brother
Steve was standing there with a
concerned look on his face he told me
I'd been screaming in my sleep and asked
me if I've been having that dream again
it made me feel like an idiot but I had
to nod and tell him yes it was the same
one this weird nightmare I've been
having day after day and despite it
almost always being the same thing it
somehow never got any less frightening
there was no way to even describe the
profound sense of dread I felt walking
down those stairs and finally seeing
what was waiting for me below even
though I could never actually remember
what it was upon waking Steve told me
not to worry about it and toss some
clothes onto my bed he assured me that
it was probably just final stress seeing
as we were a mere few months from
graduating I needed to be up in Adam
today we were touring one of our first
choice colleges my brother and I had
always been close even if we hadn't been
fraternal twins I think we still would
have been best friends all through
elementary middle and high school we
were practically joined at the hip so it
only made sense that when we were
getting close to graduation we wanted to
go to the same College we'd be friends
to the end till we were old men on the
porch and rocking chairs it so happened
that we were together in the end just
not in the way ID hoped the two of us
arrived to check out the potential
College a few hours later it was a nice
day out the brightness of the sky and
the Lush Greenery across campus quickly
banished the bitter memories of that bad
dream High School hadn't exactly been a
picnic for me I'm the nervous type if
you couldn't already tell Steve who was
the more outgoing and confident one
always looked out for me he'd always
been there whenever I was dealing with
bullies or academic stress but at
College I felt like I could reinvent
myself and become the kind of person I'd
always wanted to be as we hoop from
building to building across the tour
checking out the different facilities
and attending a few sample lectures and
seminars I was only becoming more
confident that college would be the
place for me to finally Bloom it was
perfect for me but despite this college
being exactly what I'd wanted in terms
of lifestyle and academic Pursuits there
was a certain stain on its reputation if
any University is around long enough or
any building at all for that matter
weird incidents are bound to accumulate
some places have ghost crypted sightings
this college had disappearances not just
one or two six different students in one
janitor had disappeared from the campus
the people had nothing in common except
for the fact that they frequented the
college ages races genders and Majors
varied across all the missing people and
none of them had known each other no
notes were given no clues discovered no
remains ever found a number of the cases
are even still open today it's a
frightening thought that people can just
drop off the face of the Earth like that
and never be found there are over half a
million missing person cases in the
United States back in 2020 alone it's
more common than you think still I
comforted myself with the knowledge that
thousands of new students came in and
out of the college every year and only a
handful of disappearances what were the
chances that something bad would ever
happen to me though to be fair every
person who actually did disappear in
their last moments thought what are the
chances something like this would happen
to me too we were several hours into the
tour when the coffee Steve had on the
way over finally caught up with him he
needed to go bad so we asked our tour
guide whether there was a bathroom
anywhere around here she told him that
he could find one pretty easily on the
ground floor of any Administrative
Building nearby in the meantime we'd be
making our way over to lecture hall 2B
so he could simply catch up with us
there once he was done Steve left and I
didn't think anything of it at the time
I was too wrapped up in the tour it was
only half an hour later when we were
finishing up and preparing to leave
lecture hall 2B that his absence from
the group suddenly became a lot more
noticeable I started feeling nervous
he'd just gone to the bathroom what
could be taking so long I ran through
all the more rational explanations in my
head maybe there was a long line maybe
the bathroom was out of order when he
got there and he needed to find another
one maybe he got a little lost on the
way there maybe he got a little lost on
the way back there were so many
perfectly rational reasons he wasn't
with us right now but as the minutes
dragged on each one felt a little less
likely and a dark pit of dread began to
form in my stomach it wasn't long before
I alerted the tour guide naturally she
tried to calm me down saying How likely
it is that he'd just gotten lost Steve
was a smart kid he was thinking of going
to this college after all so he must be
smart there was a smattering of laughter
from the tour group still still she put
the word out to her fellow staff members
and the search began despite trying my
best to avoid panicking the stats about
all those disappearances just kept
flashing through my mind what if we were
the Unlucky ones what if Steve had
actually disappeared just like the
others and I'd never see him again as
the hours marched on and he still wasn't
found that was all I could think about I
I didn't want to lose him I tried
calling his cell phone and texting him
countless times but got no response you
can only imagine my relief when I
suddenly got a call from him though when
I heard the content of the call that
relief quickly disappeared the reception
was patchy and his voice had a strange
Echo to it like he was somewhere deep
and cavernous there was this other noise
in the background too this strange tin
wine that felt oddly familiar I only
caught a few words from him before the
call cut out the door stay away it keeps
going something down here don't come
looking oh God if I was scared before I
was utterly mortified now I couldn't
just leave my brother in a situation
like this no matter what he told me to
do I had to find him somehow I just had
to nobody else seemed to take it
seriously but I somehow knew he was in
the most terrible danger that's when I
decided to head to the one place I
believed he would be the administrative
building it was such an unremarkable
little building hardly the kind of place
where you'd expect some terrible secret
to be hiding but dangerous things often
hide in plain sight things like the door
it was one of those things from Steve's
message that had stuck in my head that
the door call it Instinct call it
intuition call it blind dumb luck but
when I was standing in front of an
average looking door in that
unremarkable Administrative Building I
knew I was staring at the exact door
that my brother had been talking about
it radiated bad vibes Dark Energy was
practically humming off of it but I
wouldn't let that stop me perhaps I was
stupid going in without help well it's
easy to criticize from the safety of
your home it's worth remembering we do
silly things when we're afraid and I
mean this was my brother were talking
about here no one in the world was more
important to me than him no one the
second I entered the room Beyond the
Door something changed it was like
stepping into another world entirely the
air was thick and oppressive the floor
below me and the walls around me were
ungodly cold but most remarkable of all
was the dark even my phone's flashlight
at full power barely made a dent I don't
think I'd ever seen anything so truly
impenetrably dark outside of a certain
nightmare anyway that was when I finally
realized where I was standing at the top
of the stairs those stairs the stairs
that had been haunting my Restless sleep
a single winding stairwell down into the
void every part of me wanted to run and
scream and hide but I couldn't I knew
that if it were me trapped down there
Steve wouldn't have hesitated he would
have charged down there and helped me
now I had to do the same for him after
all we all know that in real life
there's no such thing as monsters and
how could a staircase really go anyway
that question was soon put to the test
as I descended down into the pit I
counted 13 steps each time before
reaching a small platform there were
strange markings and scratches on the
wall the further I descended every
footstep I took echoed on and on and on
I must have been walking for a solid 15
minutes traveling impossibly deep when I
finally heard something else I called
out Steve's name but quickly realized it
wasn't him it was a little girl weeping
a few hundred fet below I couldn't tell
if she was afraid in pain or both but
hearing it put ice in my veins what the
hell was going on down there had whoever
taken her taken Steve too what exactly
was I dealing with these were the
questions racing through my mind as I
got deeper and deeper into the belly of
the Beast time ceased to matter as the
flights went on and on beneath me even
descending into deeper colder Darkness I
was literally walking into my own
nightmare but seeing as the only
alternative was LE leaving my brother to
die down here I couldn't do anything
else I was down countless flights of
stairs when I finally saw him he was a
distant pale Speck dithering and afraid
he was a full flight down from me I was
so happy to see him that at first I
didn't even notice anything was wrong
but as I got closer I began to realize
that this wasn't the Steve I knew the
dread crept into me spreading through
every cell like a virus I finally knew
why I recognized it it was the thing for
my dreams the monster whose appearance
always brought those terrible nightmares
to an end but what did it mean to see it
in real life it was Steve's face but it
seemed larger and deathly pale I froze
and as the face Drew closer to me I
realized it had no irises no pupils no
nostrils and no mouth it wasn't my
brother it looked like a terrible
deathlike mask modeled after him I tried
to scream as it appeared right in front
of me just as I had in my dreams but it
was too late long gnarled fingers curled
around my torso and crushed my ribs it
was a pain more intense than I thought
possible and soon he even my vision went
black as I was dragged down to the
darkness below the last thought on my
mind was Steve I'm so sorry I couldn't
save you I couldn't even save myself
violent chaos unfolds across the
shoreline huge fleshy tendrils Slither
out of the water grabbing people who try
to flee and drag them into the depths as
giant harpoons made of bone whiz across
the beach cutting down unfortunate
sunbathers and droves it is a terrifying
Massac
but you'd never in a million years be
able to guess its source on April 10th
2010 something strange began to happen
in the three Portlands now the anomalous
extradimensional city state that
overlaps with the locations of Portland
Oregon Portland Maine and the aisle of
Portland is no stranger to unusual
occurrences so it took the population a
little while to notice that something
was happening but for some unknown
reason sailboats and motorboats were
beginning to vanish from the city the
disappearances occurred overnight when
there was no one around to witness them
but slowly the citizens began to notice
that their friends and family members
were going out in their watercrafts and
never returning home by April 15th the
civilians were becoming noticeably
concerned fearing the worst on April
16th their worst fears were confirmed
when two local ghosts Anar Ahmed and
Greg Moore went for a nighttime stroll
along along the harbor they heard a
sudden commotion and rushed to the scene
of the disturbance they arrived just in
time to see a living individual being
dragged into the watery depths by a
large veinlike tendril ammed asked Greg
to wait on land while he ventured out
into the water to look for the victim
unfortunately ammed never came back and
Greg took his story to the three
Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local maning
clam populace to migrate the FBI unusual
incid unit mounted a formal
investigation on the morning of April
17th all of the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been preying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11:19 a.m. 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing viny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boats
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could could
stretch as the army of fleshy boats
closed in around the shore a tugboat
broke through the surface of the water
unlike the rest of the boats it had a
noticeable hole in its Hull and was
missing its wheelhouse at an unnaturally
quick Pace the tugboat began to advance
onto land using its tendrils to drag
itself along the shore and into the more
populous part of town it grabbed
civilians at random absorbing their
blood into its metallic surface as it
went suddenly it spotted Albert ISAT a
noted member of the Church of the broken
God and began to focus its attack on him
but before the tugboat monster could
reach ISAT a city security gollem
interfered sadly though the gollum put
up a valiant fight the anomaly was able
to destroy it by Falling onto it again
and again until the gollum was no longer
able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security guard
Gollum was not one of them with the
gollum out of the way the boat continued
to drag itself through the streets
wildly crashing through the side of a
local restaurant where its owner an
entity known as the GRL was in the
middle of a busy brunch service at the
sight of the invading watercraft the GRL
set down his pitcher of bottomless
mimosas wiped his hands on his apron and
grabbed his trusty dual wield swords
from underneath the counter he kept them
there in case someone attempted to dine
and dash but he figured they would do
just fine against a blood drinking
Tugboat while the GRL kept the tugboat
busy uiu forces were able to break
through the barricade of boats for a
brief period of time allowing more
security Golems to enter the area as
well as allowing more citizens to escape
unfortunately this little victory was
short-lived as further unforeseen
Horrors drudged themselves up from the
deep the reanimated corpses of various
species native to the harbor began to
crawl out of the water surrounding the
GRL and allowing the tugboat to escape
the fight as it made its way back to the
harbor every boat it passed attempted to
toss bodies onto the tugboat covering it
in fresh blood slowly but surely the
damage to the tugboat began to repair
itself once the boat had regained its
strength it set its sights on a
previously untouched cargo ship an
observing uiu officer determined that
the boat was somehow attempting to
convert the cargo ship to transform it
into another one of its fleshy allies
but before the transformation could take
place a cargo crate broke open spilling
over 1,000 hard tack crackers suddenly
the tugboat stopped everything that it
was doing it took one tendril and began
to count each individual cracker that
had Spilled Out while the tugboat was
distracted with its task a citizen
offered the uiu use of their rare Metals
Cannonball collection in the fight to
apprehend the aggressive boat one
particular Cannonball made from electrum
was able to puncture the hole of one of
the infected ships rendering it
motionless they were elated to a found a
weapon that worked against these boats
while the tugboat continued to count the
remaining towns people gathered all of
the electrum they could find and began
to fight back against the boats one by
one the boats sank and all the while the
tugboat continued to count in the
meantime uiu officers managed to free
the GRL from his zombie attackers they
presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wielded like a
bowling ball then the GRL had a score to
settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the Gurl barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the GRL
then threw the tugboat out of the water
and continued The Savage beating before
preparing to destroy the The Battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat kemed through the air colliding
with a portal that had transported it to
the aisle of Portland luckily this
portal could only be unlocked via a
high-speed impact from a water-based
vehicle speaking of luck an SCP
Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the GRL and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of SCP
6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat SCP 6426 is a
ker class Sapient hostile entity that in
an inactive State Bears the appearance
of a harbor Tugboat in a constant state
of rust and degradation any blood or
organs containing blood that come into
contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal causing the
degradation to visibly improve as a
result the most effective blood appears
to come from humans sitations and a few
specific species of
salti the entity does not only use the
absorb blood to improve its appearance
but is also capable of using it to
create organic additions to its body
including the vein-like tend spotted in
the three Portlands Cognito hazardous
eyes attached to bending eye stocks
Harpoon guns and cannons capable of
firing ammunition made from anomalous
species of barnacles these Barnacles are
capable of reanimating dead tissue on
contact and SCP 6426 frequently uses
them to create instances of SCP
6426 C masses of reanimated tissue that
the boat uses to Aid in its attacks or
self-defense SCP e 6426 uses its
tendrils to grab prey and drag them
towards itself but the tendrils serve an
additional purpose as well each of the
tendrils has a mouth on the tip similar
in structure to that of the North
American medicinal leech when the
tendril has made contact with its prey
the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow
long and Hollow hard scales form on
their skin and their muscle mass and
bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by SCP 6426 are designated SCP
6426 d a these instances are used to the
entity's advantage helping it to extract
blood from victims at a distance as well
as providing an additional line of
defense and offense in the event that
SCP 6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use SCP 6426 daa to
convert the vehicle into an instance of
SCP 6426 DB these converted boats are
similar to SCP 6426 and are able to
function on their own however they are
unable to produce their own I stocks or
cannons unable to create SCP 6426 daa
instances and do not appear to be as
intelligent as their creator in the
early days of its containment the exact
nature of the anomaly's intelligence was
the subject of debate amongst the
research staff however on one specific
occasion the foundation was was able to
establish a line of direct communication
with SCP
6426 and conduct the first and so far
the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that SCP 6426 responded to
interview questions using the voice of
one of its victims Junior researcher
sjad Williamson in spite of his protests
was selected to conduct the interview
his fellow staff members refused to take
no for an answer and as the newest hire
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
those self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch shars Sal yes
right how rude of me yes Dr Williamson
first question concerned SCP 6426
apparent intended victim back in three
Portlands Albert ISAT SCP 6426 responded
Albert his first name is really
Albert well what other relationship is
there to say besides the Hunter and the
hunted Admiral ISAT is a ruthless Man
known for terrorizing and slaughtering
people like me he was leading a search
party of those barbaric Niles in
intending to gut me like a seal what do
you mean people like you Dr Williamson
inquired freethinkers of course people
who are unafraid to break from the mold
to carve their own path in life instead
of following the predetermined route set
by that ignorant check valve the church
is built upon a foundation of lies no
one's really a petty officer on this
ship we're all just cabin boys stumbling
around in the dark as we follow the
commands of an off and C
O if you want real power real Freedom
all you have to do is listen for the
call of the Beast open the port hole and
he'll squeeze you right
through Dr Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
um could you explicate your activities
within the harbor and how you arrived
there well after I got the bans off my
trail I found a cave to hide in I was
forced to hide in yes forced to hide
deep in the cave which turned out to be
a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel led to
some Coastal Community where I took
Refuge licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as o Zealot stocked the
surface I spent my time preparing
Gathering the strength necessary to face
them once more until I was ambushed
assaulted within my Hideout by a bwian I
fought for my life as I was forced out
into the open and descended upon by a
manner of monsters and freaks of this
orchestrated by that scumbag ISAT I was
beaten within an inch of my life before
I'm not quite sure what happened after
that I believe I was knocked unconscious
you'll have to Illuminate Me on how I
came to be in your custody at this point
the interview began to Veer in an odd
Direction the boat expressed confusion
about the nature of Williamson's
questions specifically how little they
related to the subject of sharks and
punching them it was at this point that
the site director sought guidance from
the multi Department a researcher there
informed Williamson about the confusion
SCP 6426 had mistaken the SCP Foundation
for another organization the shark
punching Center Dr Williamson resumed
the interview prepared to play along in
and keep the boat comfortable
unfortunately Williamson was a terrible
liar yes we are the shark punching
Center we will determine if you are a
suitable candidate to carry out the
mission to search punch and contain sh I
mean cations this verbal misstep caused
SCP 6426 to become suspicious after a
moment it pieced together the truth and
began to throw itself against the wall
in a desperate attempt to escape it was
apprehended by security guards who
impaled it with a naval R and returned
the watercraft to its containment cell
the exact reason for its apparent fear
and hatred of the foundation is
currently unknown and the boat has made
no attempt to speak since currently SCP
6426 is kept in a 39 MX 39 m x 50 m
containment chamber beneath the chamber
there is an artificial lava tube the
tugboat has a naval Ram through its Hull
and engine holding it in place this Ram
is checked daily for signs of
degradation as it is the primary force
keeping the anomaly immobile if the ram
is ever removed or damaged somehow a
fail safe system will activate releasing
100 hard attack crackers and two pieces
of electrum into the containment chamber
this is intended to keep the tugboat
occupied until the naval Rod can be
replaced if for some reason the naval
Rod fails and the boat runs out of heart
attack to count well there will be
nowhere on water or land that we can
hide ask anyone that has been through it
and they'll all tell you the same that
moving home is maybe one of the most
stressful things that a normal person
can ever experience it's a logistical
nightmare right from the start the
moment you talk to a realtor about being
interested in selling your current house
and buying another everything goes
downhill from there after that moment an
avalanche of things comes hurdling
towards you finding a place you like
making an offer letting people look
around your house waiting for them to
make a counter offer exchanging
contracts and that's before you even
have thought about packing and and as
Milo had learned doing all of that on
your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent but he had
finally made it after a constant back
and forth with his realer the time had
come for him to pack up all of his
worldly possessions and relocate to a
brand new place to call home he had felt
it was long overdue for him to get a
change of scenery and luckily just the
right place had come onto the market to
answer that call it was a pretty big
house bigger than Milo's previous home
but considerably cheaper in fact he
thought it had been significantly
undervalued the house had an almost
Victorian ER of feel to it all
beautifully carved and varnished
Woodwork and creaky old floorboards but
in more of an elegant refined sort of
way rather than a creepier one that's
not to say Milo's new place wasn't
without its more unsettling elements
aside from being big spacious and easy
to imagine as being haunted the
creepiest thing about the house aside
from its frighteningly low price was the
story of what happened to the previous
owners obviously you know that legally
we have to disclose whether not anyone
died on this property the realator had
explained wearing a force grin as she
showed Milo around the house hearing
that sentence he could feel the hairs on
the back of his neck stand up someone
died here he asked in disbelief no no no
no of course not sir the realtor
instantly walked back her statement Less
in an effort to ease her client's nerves
but more to ensure that she still closed
the deal and earned her commission bonus
then why the hell would you start a
sentence like that Milo asked we just
have to give full disclosure but I
assure you the previous residents didn't
die on the grounds of this house she
gave that fake smile again it was pretty
ineffectual at reassuring him so what
happened to the last owner well it's a
bit of a mystery to be honest a local
Legend if you like but hey that gives
the place more flavor hearing some
spooky history right think of what a
conversation starter that will be the
realator ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh but rained it back
in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the chaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the type Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected aware the realator was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs for
quite a while so naturally they came on
over here to see if they were in and the
last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky dory here I mean
hey better save than sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway the
realator continued of course they hadn't
sold the house they just left it when my
firm came in to repossess the place it
had all their belongings in it some
might even still be laying around here
anyway did you want to have a look at
that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his fur had reminded Milo
of the glaze sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of mosaic art the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
was something else living in the house
with them something that was Far bigger
and was getting much hungrier than
either of his pets wood looking around
the house Milo stumbled across a few
boxes that he hadn't brought with him
like the realtor had said the shaw still
had some of their possessions left lying
around the place most of it was useless
to Milo old man's clothes or a set of
knitting needles and rolls of colorful
thread it was those particular clues
that seemed to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot
of free time on her hand hands and maybe
took up knitting as a hobby during
retirement of course the bigger clue was
the huge handmade blanket that Milo
found draped over some of the remaining
boxes in the Attic he wasn't exactly
well versed in knitwear but he could
appreciate the craft behind this soft
blanket it clearly had a lot of time and
effort put into making it painstakingly
knitting each and every individual
thread looping it around a pair of Steel
needles and eventually after hours of
wearing out shaking bony fingers produce
something that actually looked quite
nice even though the idea of sitting and
knitting a blanket might have been one
of the most boring uses of time Milo
could imagine he still had to admit he
was surprised that the Shaws had left
this particular piece of bedding behind
it seemed like it would be pretty comfy
to sleep under it might help keep a
person warm at night now that the colder
seasons were approaching what's more was
that the blanket was clean almost like
it had been freshly washed there was no
old person smell on it no no dirt or
discoloration not a stain and it hadn't
even accumulated any dust in its fibers
in fact he noticed that there was hardly
any dust at all up in the attic despite
the house being empty for so long he
assumed the realators had hired someone
As a caretaker while they found a buyer
for the place and they had kept the
place clean after all what other
conclusion could they have possibly
drawn it's not as if something had eaten
all the dust that would be absurd he'd
have a sort through of the Shaw's
leftovers later maybe sell some of it
off at a local yard sale or give it to a
thrift store but that blanket might come
in handy when it started snowing so Milo
had half a mind to keep it now part of
what makes moving home such a stressful
life experience isn't just all the
logistical and administrative parts of
the process it's only made worse by the
fact that it takes forever to move into
a new house fully that's the part
everyone always forgets about the months
after a move when you're forced to live
amongst towers of of cardboard boxes all
your worldly possessions bury deep
within them and you can never remember
which crate anything is in when you
urgently need it so realizing it would
take him much longer to unpack all of
his things Milo set about making sure he
had everything that donut and pixel
would need already to hand the latter of
his two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day dut on the other hand was much more
of a free spirit the tiny brown hamster
physically could not stay still and most
a seemed to be filled with more energy
than Milo was as a result he let the
little guy roll about inside a little
plastic ball all day long until his
little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the realators
had pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown fate of
the previous residence wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seene
to make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creek
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturbance that emanated
from some hidden corner of the building
only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down at
nighttime every squeaky floorboard or
random noise of the house settling was
nearly deafening enough to pull Milo
right out of what little Restless sleep
he was getting the worst part about it
was though he couldn't help it it made
him feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs sha
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shaws showing the pair of
them staring dis approvingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night Milo is seeing
the old couple in every bad dream he had
both their faces were locked in those
same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they tried to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail in the coffin
that made Milo realized he needed to
look at other options surely there had
to be some way to induce a deep enough
sleep so that the sounds the house was
making weren't keeping him up or
incepting nightmares anymore he called
the local doctor arranging a
consultation for later that day as he
hung up the phone something nudged
against his foot it was donut having
rolled through the Maze of cardboard
boxes still filling the house Milo took
one look at the little brown fur hamster
then the crates that still littered the
place grabbing the leftover items that
the shots had forgotten to take with
them before they vanished Milo moved
those boxes out into the the shed he
knew he was probably reaching that it
was hard likely to make even the
slightest difference to his sleeping but
maybe keeping their stuff away from him
would keep the old couple out of his
head the only thing he kept in the house
was the blanket there was no use letting
it go to waste especially knowing that
the boiler was on the blink and it would
be cold soon he rolled it up and left it
on his bed leaving his more mobile pet
in the same room before heading out to
see the doctor when Milo got back a
bottle of prescription sleep pills in
his pocket he couldn't help but notice
his room seemed different the blanket
looked like it had fallen off the bed
and onto the floor for one but more
worryingly Donut's plastic travel ball
had been split open laying in pieces on
the ground with its furly little
occupant nowhere to be seen over the
next few hours Milo searched every
corner of the house calling out to his
hamster trying to lure it back with more
morsels of food but donut didn't seem to
be anywhere he wasn't even underneath
the knitted blanket still there was no
sign as worry set in Milo hurly checked
pixel's cage to see if he was gone too
but the lizard was relaxing as lethargic
as ever completely unfazed by what was
going on it certainly seemed that when
it rained it really poured in his new
house just as he was searching for his
missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it
finally giving out after God knows how
many years it had been installed for The
house's boiler burst spending the
afternoon into the evening failing to
track down one of his Missing Pets and
stopping the huge ironcast boiler from
flooding the basement wasn't exactly
what Milo had in mind for fun activities
to do when he got home going to bed
frustrated made it as hard to sleep as
all the nightly cacophony of creaking
floorboards and branches raking against
the windows he tapped out two of the
pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too and not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the gnawing cold
the pills did as they were meant to
helping Milo to quickly sleep into a
much deeper sleep than he had
experienced in a while although it
didn't seem to help the nightmares Mr
and Mrs Shaw came back again this time
they had Milo's arms and legs tied up
with their matching disapproving faces
the elderly couple threw something over
their helpless victim and tried to
smother him to death for a dream it felt
so intense so real Milo could feel a
heavy weight on top of his body as he
slept in fact it felt like it was all
around him engulfing and crushing the
life out of him from all sides but it
was the feeling of something wet against
his arm the sensation of liquid against
his skin and the numbness where his hand
should be were what finally pulled him
out of the dream and into the nightmare
through the dark and his cloudy vision
Milo could see a wide gaping ma filled
with teeth the feeling of being crushed
was still surrounding him and despite
kicking his legs and trying to free
himself from confinement it didn't stop
squeezing him tighter his Panic was
already making it harder to catch his
breath but now he could barely feel his
lungs enough to scream for help not that
anyone was around to hear him but it was
the side of his arm that chilled Milo's
blood it wasn't there anymore part of it
just above the elbow was just gone his
hand fingers every internal bone and
muscle had been reduced to a bloody mess
a slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's underwater and becomes sludge most
of his flesh was liquefied going further
up his arm and as the blanket pulled its
prey into its mouth until Milo was no
more not a trace of him left just like
the previous owners little did Milo or
the Shaws and donut before him know but
he'd been the victim of a creature that
was part of a rather unique species well
they will often vary in size shape
pattern and other aspects of their
appearance SCP 799 always seemed to be
ordinary items of knitted bedwear at
least at first they retain heat like a
normal blanket wood and are soft to the
touch and for the most part don't seem
directly harmful and usually they aren't
SCP 799 are incapable of much movement
instead laying still a lot of time not
unlike a certain bearded dragon that
just lost its owner they also don't seem
to require much in the way of food
extracting what little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an SCP 799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
well they possess this biological trait
themselves SCP 799 don't seem to regard
coldblooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with cold
blood such as reptiles in instead SCP
799 will metamorphose into a more
predatory form in order to consume any
warm-blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body Mass to feet itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live the diver screams A Silent Scream
as the giant Squid's beak digs into his
skin it's many grasping tentacles
grabbing him and holding him in place
nearby his fellow divers are driven half
mad with Terror as they see mysterious
figures floating towards them through
the MC and strange Russian voices
speaking in their heads nobody can help
them they're down too deep too consumed
by the darkness and the pressure of the
sea they're now at the mercy of whatever
is inside the submarine beginning in the
1940s with the dawn of nuclear weapons
the American government conducting the
world's first atomic weapons test and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with
nuclear testing of their own the two
Powers entered an arms race fueled by
rivalry and a thirst to prove their
strength on the world stage What
followed were Decades of Staggering
technological advancements as each
Nation tried to outdo and intimidate the
other the Soviet Union crossed into the
cold reaches of outer space deploying
the satellite Sputnik the United States
responded with the founding of NASA
tensions reached a fever pitch during
the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962 as
United States citizens feared they were
teetering on the brink of nuclear war in
July of 196 68 the Soviet Union the
United Kingdom and the United States
came together to sign the treaty on the
nonproliferation of nuclear weapons
agreeing to abandon their pursuit of
increasing nuclear power and turn their
focus to disarmament but several months
before the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as SCP
741 SCP 741 is the underwater wreckage
of a Soviet submarine that sank in March
of 1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 197 7s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uid or ker
class anomaly in the r at this point it
passed into the custody and surveillance
of the foundation the submarine is on
the ocean floor broken into three pieces
the hle was broken into bits during
project redacted recovery attempt but
was largely intact when it first s sank
except for two holes one just in front
of the sail and one just below the
starboard missile tubes apparently the
vessel sank rapidly due to flooding
after an enemy missile strike which
occurred while it was surfacing though
all parts of the submarine are accounted
for no members of the crew have been
located additionally none of the
emergency escape equipment on board has
been used raising further questions
about what became of the crew wherever
they went they seem to have left
something behind mind whenever divers
are sent down to investigate the
wreckage they report experiencing
anomalous currents and strange sea life
and hearing moans disembodied voices and
incoherent Whispering they also report
seeing blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a Mann Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described in incident report 174 41- a
divers a26 through a30 embarked from the
Icebreaker yamal into the waters below
with the intention of studying the
potential anomalous activity surrounding
the wreckage as the group of divers
approached the submarine they could feel
the shift in the water around them the
oppressive feeling of abnormally
increasing pressure bearing down and
threatening to crush them if their
specialized diving equipment were to
fail they knew that that would be it and
the command would have to come and fish
their Corpses out of the water or even
worse they would vanish entirely meeting
the same mysterious fate as the crew of
that doomed submarine but they couldn't
fix it on that they had a job to do at
first glance the wreckage appeared
undisturbed unchanged since the previous
inspection still they needed to take a
closer look to be sure as the team got
closer to the vessel a30 was startled by
the sight of movement from within the
wreckage spotting motion through one of
the holes in the structure as something
passed by by he pointed it out to his
colleagues but they dismissed it as
likely a giant isopod or spider crab
which were crawling all over the
surrounding area a30 laughed off his
jumpiness agreed that they were probably
right and continued the exploration as
planned control authorized the divers to
proceed to the next step and a29
activated sonar and lights moving toward
the starboard side breach there a faint
glowing caught his eye the glow
resembled that of radioactive material
but when when the team checked the
radiation levels in the area they
remained stable whatever the source of
the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
Vini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerged from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like a
person the other divers quickly noted
the apparation too and began to panic
some checked their nitrogen levels
believing it to be some sort of nitrogen
Narcosis While others pointed out that
they couldn't all be suffering from
nitrogen Narcosis at the same time the
unknown voice continued speaking saying
help me it is getting hard to breathe
the divers debated what to do next
questioning whether what they were
seeing was even real when all at once
the humanoid figure vanished from sight
the divers attempted to shake off the
startling encounter and they resumed
their duties the investigation
proceeding as normal after a few moments
of uneventful work another Interruption
presented itself in the form of a 5 m
long squid swimming around the wreckage
its presence startled the divers at
first particularly those closest to the
animal but the others encouraged them to
ignore it
citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squid circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible an order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver 826 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well as threatening the
safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the rack the few records that the
foundation has managed to obtain from
the Russian and US governments indicate
that the submarine was being used to
transport some sort of secret cargo
though the specifics of this cargo are
still unknown there is reason to believe
that it differed from any type of
nuclear or chemical Weaponry on a date
redacted from official files the scps
basti was patrolling the area around SCP
741 when it sonar detected some unknown
entity approaching SCP 741 from the
south at a pace of 46 knots the crew
compared the acoustic signature of the
contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find find a
match the bisti attempted to reach the
contact via sonab Bui drops and active
sonar pings but it did not respond when
the contact crossed into the total
underwater exclusion Zone it became
classified as hostile at that point the
sonar recorded sounds of an underseen
missile launch and basti responded with
the utmost urgency the ship broke away
from its original area and fired a type
53 torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the bisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an un identified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 m and a
velocity of .92 Mach the missiles did
not emit any detectable radar nor did
they respond to any launch chaff or
flares from the basti both of the
missiles were engaged by bassist's 3K N5
Kinsel surfac to- aair missiles and
cachan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 18800 M and 210 M from
Impact respectively after the missiles
were neutralized the Hostile vessel
could could be heard engaging in evasive
maneuvers at this point there were four
closely spaced explosions and the sound
of a submarine disintegrating the
identity of the attacker as well as its
intention toward SCP 741 have not yet
been determined the incident resulted in
the foundation research team suggesting
an expansion of the acoustic sensor net
as well as additional Patrol and defense
assets placed in the area additionally
they advised an acquisition of undersea
retaliatory capability the incident was
classified incident 1741 DC the sonar
recordings from the scps bisti during
incident 1741 DC were taken for further
analysis by the research team the
in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government or organization following the
incident involving the scps bisti an
American intelligence agent reached out
to the foundation offering further
insight into the secretive government
programs looking into SCP 741 he agreed
to sit for an interview with a
foundation researcher assigned to the
project on the condition that his
identity remained protected the SCP
researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff the redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crew Men We buried Just
Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand load
in the sink just no bodies left when I
first looked into all this I had no clue
what the hell had gone on down there but
I started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at v preparent as spies wind
up owing each other favors after a while
and they denied it vly not your usual
cover up balone either they clearly
stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted
know part of it sound like he was going
to puke when I mentioned redacted doctor
do you have any idea what it takes to
make a bioweapons researcher sick now
that wasn't what really bugged me though
what really kept me awake at night was
the KGB file that fell into our hands
they mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapon that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like like Russia thinks so too Lan and
you half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 741 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets as CP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea you've
been walking for days your body aches
you're dripping with sweat from The Heat
Of The Sun bearing down overhead and yet
you're wrapped up in layers upon layers
of clothing even your face is covered
and you're wearing thick black goggles
so that not a single centimeter of your
body body is exposed your journey has
been long and you feel like you might
die from exhaustion or from overheating
due to these multiple layers of clothes
but dying is better than being exposed
you saw it happen when your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those You Used To Know no cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby SCP Foundation containment
facility site 46 any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the S of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you wen't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail Trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left a jar
the facility reeks of those things but
you can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take Echoes
through the empty Halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level B5 ker
containment lucky for you it seems all
the cells are empty now the horrors that
were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coupe you keep following
that slimy black Trail until you find an
abandoned office there are no no people
here anymore just a broken barricade
some empty medicine bottles and a bucket
that the people inside the office had
apparently been using as a toilet you
breathe a sigh of disappointment at
finding no one alive here but you're at
least relieved to be out of the sun you
can finally remove your jacket and head
wrap with your uncovered eyes you notice
that a nearby computer terminal is still
powered up you sit down at the desk and
turn on the monitor because of the
emergency procedure procedures put into
place in a k-class scenario like this
safeguards no longer apply you can
access all the information you need up
to and including finding out what
actually happened in the dull glow of a
nearby emergency light you see a dark
shape slumping through the halls in
Shadow you tense up then exhale as it
slithers off into an adjoining Hall
you're safe for now the terminal has
finally loaded and authenticated your
access your you're staring at the file
for SD locks proposal for SCP 001 when
day breaks it's the only name you can
give the apocalypse your world is
currently experiencing this is one of
the only anomalies in the entire history
of the SCP Foundation to be given the
apolon containment class meaning
containment is truly impossible SCP 001
is the most dangerous enemy that the
foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the SCP Foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
SCP 001 and those effects are Beyond
horrifying the SCP Foundation
administrator released an urgent memo
telling Foundation Personnel to make
their way to site 19 at all costs
because they need all the help they can
get those exposed to SCP 001 in the
process are no longer considered human
their new designation is SCP
001a these new entities are to be
avoided at all costs but in case of
emergencies the administrator says it is
permitted to cut off parts of your
transformed comrads and eat them to
avoid starvation no attempt should be
made to kill them since you won't
succeed you'll just put yourself at risk
when the sun changed and became SCP 001
it instantly affected 6.8 billion
innocent people the second the visible
light touched them whether it was from
the Sun itself or even reflected off the
moon their bodies liquefied melting like
candle wax into puddles of living
gelatinous slime this effect isn't
isolated to humans either any biological
entity exposed to sunlight immediately
under the same irreversible melting
process into
scp1 a and the horror had only just
begun people transformed into SCP 001a
will remain shades of their Former
Intelligence and personality they may
even try to will their new gooey Mass
into a shape resembling their original
form however these individuals will lose
their sense of self if they come into
contact with other instances of SCP 0000
1- a when they come together 001 d a
instances will bond on a molecular level
waiting up into horrific giant blobs
with only one purpose integrating more
matter into their bodies that's why they
have to be avoided at all costs you
continue to search the computer terminal
for answers perhaps there was some kind
of contingency plan put in place for
this some way to reverse the effects or
at least escape the nightmare Earth has
become instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the SCP 001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were researcher Dr Logan igata her
partner Ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others Dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world in the first audio log Dr igata
and her companion seemed afraid but
hopeful that there may be some way out
of this situation Dr igata reported that
most of the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realized things may not have been as
hopeful as stock rata L on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining DCL classes
wearing a full protective suit he didn't
last long the huge creature grabbed him
with tentacles made of reconstituted
flame flesh it began ripping off his
protective suit as he screamed for Mercy
it was a monster made of dozens of
people and animals he could never
overpower it the second the Sun Touched
his skin he melted away and was absorbed
by the great Mass holding him in place
guns were ineffective against these SCP
001 D super entities fire would do no
good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense block mobs down and even
then not permanently there was one ray
of light in the darkness the site
director had a secret tunnel underneath
his office connected to a tram that
could hopefully take them directly to
site 19 without risk of SCP 001 exposure
it was a good plan and by far the best
option they had available to them but
the best plans often don't work in
practice you open the next Detachment on
the terminal this time it's a video feed
you can actually see Dr Logan igata and
she looks harrowed by what she's
experienced as it turns out while the
others including her partner Ari
attempted to escape through the tunnel
something had happened Dr igata heard
AR's voice over her radio but there was
something wrong with it it was too low
too guttural and filled with gurgles SCP
001 had gotten her she was changed the
monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
Escape now seemed gone Ari told Dr igata
that it would be fine that it was such a
bright beautiful sunny day outside and
she was wasting it locked up inside that
office she tormented Dr IG with their
shared memories of picnics in the park
on sunny days in the past the monster
with AR's voice did everything it could
to try to convince Dr igata to give up
up and join them but she wasn't ready to
go just yet you look away from the
screen when you hear a sound in the
corner you see a dark puddle of some
unknown substance and then some skeletal
hands rising out of it the hands are
pulling themselves out of the puddle
followed by a skeletal face covered in
matted hair you have to stop yourself
from screaming until a flash from a
nearby security light makes the figure
disappear it's a normal puddle once
again your mind is playing tricks on you
you open the next attachment another
video and see that Dr ot's condition has
deteriorated she looked pale frantic and
thin she was using a knife to draw her
own blood onto a piece of bloodstained
parchment covered in strange symbols it
got a ranted about her Theory what if
001 took the minds and bodies of its
victims but not their souls through
performing some kind of Arcane blood
ritual she hoped to at least rescue and
keep the soul of Ari even if if her mind
and body were lost you open the next
attachment it seemed that agata's ritual
worked but not in the way she hoped the
Twisted soul of arri driven mad by SCP
001 had taken over the file it begins
corrupting the text of the SCP 001 file
into crazy ranting about how feudal it
is to fight it then cuts to an even more
frightening video feed Dr igata in her
sleep tossing and turning in a makeshift
bed in the corner of her office the
camera approaches her in first person
and lingers over her sleeping body an
oily skeletal hand reaches P the camera
and runs its fingers through Dr igot's
hair it's that exact same hand you saw
reaching out of that black puddle
earlier you must have seen AR's
lingering spirit with a lump in your
throat you open the next attachment and
watch the video you see Dr igata now
truly broken she'd been haunted by AR's
demonic spirit for a long time now and
it has clearly taken its toll she is
waving around a handgun while she speaks
she now believes there's only one way to
escape but not like this she doesn't
want the gun to draw attention to her
body she doesn't want to become part of
that mass even if she is dead she opens
a drawer on her desk she's recording at
and places the gun inside Dr igata then
apologizes to her loved ones who are
likely long since dead or assimilated
and turns off the recording for the last
time in that moment you realize there's
a single drawer in the desk in front of
you when you reach forward and open it
you see the same handgun Dr igata was
holding is laying inside you pick it up
and study it weighing your options
perhaps there truly is no other way out
then you see an update on the file one
more attachment has been added while you
were studying the gun you feel your
heart pounding in your chest as you
reach forward and and open the
attachment the text has been changed
entirely the file on SCP 001 is now a
poem an OE to the Sun and to ultimate
togetherness then a video file
spontaneously opens itself on the screen
it's a video of you shot from behind you
see those oily skeletal hands reaching
for you in the dark just like they did
with Dr igata in that moment you panic
and fire the gun behind you hoping to
scare off the spirit instead the sound
of the gunshots attracts something far
worse the immense blob of screaming
melted flesh charges towards the office
you try to barricade the door but it is
not enough the flesh seeps and bursts
through and grabs you in its meaty
tentacles you scream and try to escape
but it won't save you nothing will save
you the flesh carries you upstairs out
through the empty Halls out into the
cave you can see the light in the
distance as the blob fies you towards it
you won't be alone for much longer in
fact you won't be alone ever again now
check out SCP 001 the Scarlet King and
SCP 001 which is the real 001 for more
deep dives into SCP 001 Mysteries and
lore